kurt i was leaving a spot up here for
you but i see that you're back here
yeah
we might not
we're trying to see if representative
langley the best place for her to be but
i think
down here we can move a table out and
exactly
smart
see
that's effective leadership right
is
questions
it is
good morning everyone
we'll call this meeting of the house
there is a switch that says mic switch
and it's on
okay
test
good
while he's turning on the mic
i just uh
indicate
uh that
our
uh
hearing this morning we're going to
begin our with our hearing this morning
we are going to
limit people to a particular time limit
because we have so many uh
people to speak i went through the cards
this morning there are only two people
uh that ask for more than three minutes
on their cards
and one of them being the sponsor of the
bill
so i'm going to limit everybody to three
minutes uh which i think is fair
except for the sponsors
who i think should have adequate
opportunity to explain
if not what i'm going to do is i'm going
to go down front i think and
is that yep
working now
thank you
and as i said we're going to limit
speakers to three minutes and we do have
someone who'll be
timing us today
the um
just for the committee just in terms of
organization i just and for the
committee's planning
we are scheduled for a session next week
and that
session will be on wednesday and
thursday the 16th and the 17th
and what i would like to do is on the
18th friday the 18th is have an
executive session
the uh and that will give us by doing
that uh we can get uh exec these bills
that we're hearing today and the one
other bill that we heard previously that
hasn't been exact yet
but that would
that would be able to free us up so we
would have that next week free and i
think probably two weeks free before we
get enough senate bills in order to
start having hearings again
so it'd give us two weeks off
so plan on the morning of the 18th for
executive session
our first item of business this morning
is a hearing on house bill
yes
oh yes
my clerk reminds me that before we begin
today we have to have a roll call of our
committee members and salute the flag so
well if we could do the pledge of
allegiance and representative notter
through the fire
of the united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation
under god indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
thank you and mr clerk would you take
representative
representative alexander
representative andrus
representative birch
representative chase
representative lorenzo
representative gordon
here representative greene
representative oregon
you have to use your microphone
whoops representative kenny
is my microphone on
just pull the mic down close to your
mouth if you would representative wilbur
i can put it right here how's that
okay
i can put it right here like that
representative macbeth
representative mclean
here representative mirner
here representative notter
here representative page here
representative simpson here
representative marjorie smith
representative sylvia
representative trottier
and the court representative welper is
here
thank you mr clerk
again our first item of business this
morning is house bill 1181 allowing the
biological father of an unborn child
to petition the court for an injunction
prohibiting the biological mother from
having an abortion the primary sponsor
of this bill was representative greeson
and representative greeson if you would
approach the microphone we would like to
hear your testimony and again i'm just
going to limit you to the five minutes
you
requested all right
thank you mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee i'm
representative jeff greason of wentworth
i represent grafton county district 16
and i'm here today to introduce to you
house bill 1181
this bill tackles a very controversial
and sensitive issue but there does not
need to be any controversy with this
bill as it simply addresses a gap or
deficiency that legal precedents and
laws have failed to close or to remedy
to date
in its roe vs wade decision the united
states supreme court established a right
of personal privacy protected by the due
process clause that includes the right
of a woman to determine whether or not
to bear a child
the supreme court has repeatedly
affirmed that the state has a vested
interest in protecting the life of the
pre-born baby while simultaneously
protecting the rights of the pregnant
woman
in planned parenthood versus casey the
supreme court ruled that in order to
protect the central right recognized in
roe versus wade while at the same time
accommodating the state's profound
interest in potential life
the undue burden standard should be
employed this means an undue burden
exists and therefore a provision of law
is invalid if its purpose or effect is
to place substantial obstacles in the
path of a woman seeking an abortion
before the fetus attains viability
the supreme court has also stated that
the pregnant woman bears a greater
burden than the father therefore the
protection of her rights is of greater
weight than the father's rights
and although the supreme court has
stated that the protection of the
woman's rights is of greater weight they
have never said that the father has
no rights
no uterus no opinion is not the law
that's only been standard operating
procedure since 1973.
this bill maintains the state's interest
in the life of the pre-born baby
protects all the rights of the pregnant
woman but now recognizes the rights of
the father
and in recognition of the greater burden
naturally being on the pregnant woman
this bill ensures that the greater
burden is placed on the father but at
least now he has an opportunity to have
his voice heard and his rights
recognized
what this bill does is allow the father
of a pre-born baby to file a pre a
petition with the local court in his
jurisdiction for an injunction to
prevent the woman who is pregnant with
his child from obtaining an abortion in
order that he may raise the child
this bill avoids conflict with all
established legal precedents it avoids
conflict with
planned parenthood versus casey and
planned parenthood versus danforth which
declared that the pregnant woman does
not have to inform the father of the
baby of her pregnancy even if the father
is her husband this bill assumes the
father knows of the pregnancy by
whatever means the woman is not required
to tell the father
this bill avoids any undue burden by
requiring the injunction be approved or
denied within any established
gestational limits in the state of new
hampshire that was recently established
at 24 weeks this means the injunction
must be approved or denied before 24
weeks gestation in order to allow
sufficient time for the pregnant woman
to obtain an abortion should the
injunction be denied
this bill maintains protection of the
woman's rights in the case of rape or
incest it protects the woman's rights as
it pertains to her physical health
this bill goes even further to protect
the rights of the woman by allowing her
to obtain an abortion after the
gestational limit 24 weeks here in new
hampshire at the father's expense if the
injunction has to be revoked due to his
actions this prevents fathers from
abusing the injunctive process
this bill does not allow an injunction
to be granted if the father has been
convicted of any sexual crimes violent
crimes or crimes against children
this bill requires the petitioner to
execute a voluntary acknowledgement of
paternity that is not subject to be
rescinded or challenged this means only
the actual biological father of the
child
can be granted an injunction
if the pregnant woman denies the
petitioner's paternity the petitioner
may request dna testing but he is
required to pay the cost of that testing
for both him and her
and if the dna testing shows he is not
the father the petition is immediately
denied
this bill protects the woman's personal
safety throughout the entire process she
may attend all medical appointments
without the father being present if she
has any concerns for personal safety she
may request a restraining order against
the father and that is up to the
discretion of the judge to issue
the father has additional financial
responsibilities to the pregnant woman
throughout pregnancy her only
responsibilities are
to excuse me ensure proper care of
herself and the baby throughout
pregnancy upon birth the mother has no
obligations to the child or the father
and her name will even be omitted from
the baby's birth certificate
this bill presents a simple common sense
means of closing the gap that exists in
current legal precedent and law by
ensuring the rights of the father are
recognized with its proper weight in
this very sensitive subject
his rights remain to of lesser weight
than hers
but this bill ensures that the weight of
his right is actually now considered
thank you
thank you are there any questions for
representative greeson yes
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
um so you mentioned that the bill
recognizes um the right of the father
but it preserves you know the relative
weight of of the father versus the
mother so i just kind of want to get
some insight into your thinking as to
what kind of situations an injunction
when it would be granted
when
what's what situations if you were to
petition the if the father were to
petition the court
can you walk me through a situation
where you think
this is this this would warrant
um the granting of the injunction given
the relative right to the mother and the
father
man finds out that a woman is pregnant
with his child
presumably all right
at that point that he finds out and
again she is not legally obligated to
inform him he finds out
he is able to go before the court and re
and petition the court if he is assuming
that there's there's a reasonable
assumption that she would seek an
abortion
at some time
he can petition the court at that point
he has to declare that he is the father
if she challenges that
then that's he he would then have to say
i would like dna testing and dna
advancements or they can get the results
back within a week so that's not an
overburden on anybody but he has to pay
for that
um assuming that he is the biological
father of the child
at that point the the the injunction
once the in a legal proceeding once
there is a petition for an injunction
unless it is immediately rejected for
some reason the injunction
is temporarily
automatically put in place if i'm
understanding the law correctly and if
there's a someone who a judge that can
correct me on that that would be fine
but my understanding is that the
injunction is a temporary injunction
to allow for
the process to be heard
so in other words he files the petition
for an injunction she says oh no a
petition was filed i'm going to go out
and get an abortion at that at that
moment there's a service time there
again it could happen if she does it
before she served with the end with the
uh with with the paperwork informing her
but assuming she doesn't do that
then that's where the details of
everything comes out
again the judge is going to hear the
case of i am the biological father i
want to be able to raise this child as
my own she is under no further
obligation of
of that
i just want the child to be able to
raise the child for my for my own the
judge would then go through the process
with him this is what the law requires
this is uh what your obligations are
financially to her to the child
throughout the process and then she
would understand what her rights are
through all of that again the judge
would explain all that to them and
assuming that there is no
criminal
past history of his that would prevent
the the uh the injunction for all
intents and purposes it would go through
there would have to be a reason to deny
it
uh and so as long as he's the biological
father and he's he doesn't have a a
criminal history
uh and then if there are any other
instructions that the judge would would
issue on that uh a restraining order
stay in uh so many distance apart or you
are not allowed to go to any of the
medical appointments with her any
instructions from the judge and if he
violates those instructions from the
judge like any other
instructions from a judge there are
penalties that come with that and one of
those penalties would be if the judge
has to rescind the injunction then she
can go and and if she chooses to at that
point still even after the 24 weeks she
would be able to obtain the abortion
it it's
it would it would the the process would
be
that
as long as there's nothing to deny it
then
representative dilorenzo
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question representative
what would happen in the event that two
or more men
well only one gets to win
because i don't know that there's ever
been two men impregnate the same woman
so
only the biological father
follow-up
well this is a time sensitive
issue
what would be the process for
determining the father
i can imagine a situation where a woman
has been raped by two or more men
and
every one of those men could claim to be
the father
only only one man is going to be the
father
that's
it is
but how is that determined how do you
get there
well if there's a question there can be
thank you for taking my question thank
you representative page
uh thank you mr chair thank you for
taking my question representative
i'm looking at the bill and i see
there's been some consideration for
costs associated with a pregnancy
including
prenatal the father would or the
alleged father would be
responsible for things like prenatal
vitamins and a 250 a month
payment i guess to the mother for
purposes of proper and adequate
nutrition
i'm wondering to what extent you also
might have considered
other costs that might be associated
with
both
the time the duration of the pregnancy
and post-pregnancy for example
um
you know i know some some mothers that
can't work because
of their pregnancy there'd be a loss of
income there
and then i'm wondering
to what extent you consider perhaps i
mean could a child support
going forward after the birth of the
child could that be something
that the mother could petition the court
in the same proceeding
to do and then my in a related point
what if what i know under the american
rule of fees and courts
we have
ace parties responsible for their own
attorney's fees
i'm wondering what happens in the event
that
you know the mother has to bear the
costs of going to court and then
ultimately she prevails
should the father be responsible for her
attorney's fees as well so it's
kind of my questions within that but
they concern the costs associated both
before and after the birth of the child
actually excellent questions and um
first of all
the the greater weight is being placed
the greater burden excuse me the greater
burden is being placed on the father as
it should be
he should be on the hook for
the expenses of this
i have no issues with that that's the
way it should be
as far as
child support or anything like that
after the birth
she's giving up the baby she has no
obligations to the baby after birth she
didn't want the baby he does
so she should not have any obligations
to the baby whatsoever after the child
is born now if you're suggesting that we
amend the bill to allow the father or
require excuse me require the father to
pay some sort of compensatory uh
costs of postpartum uh care i'm all in
favor of that let's let's let's put him
on the hook for that absolutely she went
through all the process the greater
burden on the on the of the of the
natural childbirthing process
uh let him let him pay for some time off
from work let him pay he's on the hook
for any any medical expenses not covered
by her insurance
as he should be
so if we want to amend this bill that
would require him to pay some some
period of time
whatever that period of time may be to
allow for postpartum care
i'd be all in favor of that that he
would that he would care but her
obligations to the child
are after the child is born she's under
yes representative corrigan
thank you very much mr chair thank you
mr representative greeson um
i'm uh looking at the bill and i don't
see any provisions for the uh women for
the uh
for the mother to specify uh
to prevent the uh
the supposed father from getting any
particular medical procedures like uh
such as a vasectomy or a uh
or even a gender reassignment surgery
that would be somewhat unusual
circumstance but um
so does this give the mother any control
over the
alleged father's medical decisions
i didn't catch all of what you said
there however gender reassignment
surgery has absolutely nothing to do
absolutely nothing to do with this
other questions
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um
i guess first i want to congratulate you
i think this is a first
in terms of proposals related to
reproductive rights that have appeared
before this committee over the years
usually you know you say there's nothing
new under the sun and this might be in
something new and so i'd like to
congratulate you for that
thank you no no no i i i i i'm thinking
of the movie the croods where he says
they tried something new and died i hope
that's not a premonition you just had
sorry um
i didn't quite hear that i'm sure it was
clever but i didn't quite hear that
um
is as to exactly what the purpose
of this
bill is um
i see what the process is but i don't
quite see
and
is the purpose to protect
the
woman involved is the pro is the purpose
to protect the rights of the biological
father
is the purpose to protect um
the fetus
i'm just not
sure and i wonder if you could help me
the answer to that is yes
and i don't mean that facetiously
again this is this is
this is a juggling act the state has to
balance between the interest in in
protecting the life of the of the of the
child
as well as protecting the rights of the
mother and to date nothing has ever been
done
considering the father
and so this brings that
piece into
the into the discussion now
so it's it's not just about protecting
the rights of the father
it's it's actually about recognizing
that
men have the rights the fathers have
but how do we go about making sure that
those rights are recognized so the
purpose is there may be a man out there
who would love to raise this child
how many there are i have no idea nobody
knows how many
but there may be a man out there who
says i am the father of this child i
would like to raise this child as my own
if she doesn't want to so be it but i'm
willing to
how you know how terrible for a man to
take responsibility for his actions
right
and so
he's gonna the purpose is to to at least
codify in law and recognize
that fathers do have rights
though they may be of lesser weight
they do have some and so it's just to
make sure that those get recognized mr
mr could i just follow up a follow-up
thank you
um
representative greeson i've read this
bill i'm sure that i haven't read it as
often and as many times as you have
but i see nowhere in this bill language
the
if in fact the pregnancy because of
these actions were to come full term
and
there would be a product of the
pregnancy able to live outside of the
mother
and
that
the father will assume
all
responsibilities
for
raising
that child
i see no indication anywhere in this
that the father's obligation
extends past the moment
of birth
and
if in fact
as you say
your concern is to protect the fetus and
if you acknowledge that for whatever
reason
the the woman
under the law
chooses to end the pregnancy
and you want to
interfere with that
wouldn't there then be an obligation
to state who is going to be responsible
for raising
um
the results of this pregnancy that says
that he is the purpose for him
petitioning is because he wants to raise
the child as his own
thank you very much you might want to go
back and look at the language thank you
thank you
are there other questions
yes representative maclean
yeah thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question just a just a quick
follow-up on on the question i asked
earlier because i think there was some
confusion about the question what i'm
really looking at trying to determine is
what is the end result so there is a
process and it goes
in pretty good detail here about the
injunction process but you know
understanding your recognition of the
relative rights of the mother and the
father
is it the intent of this bill
that if
the father is identified as the father
through dna which it kind of goes
through here
and they
want to raise the child
is that
the is it is it the intent of this bill
that that is grounds to stop the
abortion
that in itself and not some other
he is filing a petition
to prevent an abortion from taking place
in order that he may have the child to
that's it
okay
other questions
representative page i have another
question
thank you thank you mr chairman thank
you for taking my question
as i read this
this question relates to personal
jurisdiction
over the over the mother as it in terms
of potentially bringing the mother here
to new hampshire
if we had a scenario
where the conception happened in florida
with the mom is a floridian
and dad is a granite stater
the new hampshire court
could then have jurisdiction over the
mom who maybe never had
contacts in new hampshire is that
correct and if so
do you feel that that is some sort of
some sort of violation of a state's
rights
of the floridian
if you follow my question that is a
legal question that can get duked out at
the supreme court
within the state of new hampshire or
whatever that is that is a legal
hypothetical that i cannot answer
seeing none thank you representative
greeson
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee
i'm walter stapleton
representative for claremont ward 3
sullivan county district 5.
i am a co-sponsor in support of hp 1181
establishing
affirming rights of the father in the
cases
you know in the scotus decisions
at both roe v wade and planned
which both enabled
an affirmed abort the right of abortion
they did say that a woman's right of
privacy was not autonomous or exclusive
that the state
has a valid and reasonable interest
in protecting
life in the womb
these
and how does that happen
well
the father is a partner in procreation
and
the that's a natural
right of
both parties
to be recognized in that
and it also brings responsibility
to both parties
for the care and the raising of that
child
in the case of abortion we have a
different circumstance here of course
because
if the child is aborted
well the state loses its uh
valid and reasonable interest
the child loses its life
and there's no further
action that can be done
by the father
the father has been silent
we hear about women's choice
and the right to abortion
and
we never hear anything about
the father's choice
and yet the father is an instrument in
this procreation
so
out of natural law
and out of
the state's reasonable and valid
interest
the father represents standing
for that state interest as well has his
own interest as a father
and the state interest is important
and the woman's interests is important
and the father's interest is important
is why we need this bill
even though we haven't expressly
made that
affirmation of the father's rights
why because it's part of natural law
it's been understood from eons
that of
father and mother are participants in
creation
and you know by that very same natural
law
as recognized by
the laws in our country and democracy
parents are responsible for raising
their children for their safety and care
so
when the father is allowed the right
to have a say
it prevents the abortion
and he assumes that responsibility
for custodian care
safety raising the child in the case
that the mother may not want to
participate in that
but those are other things beyond this
bill is establishing a father's right
we're not going to stretch out
into the whole entire life and aspect of
the child
we're protecting the father's right to
have a say
to give him a chance to preserve the
life that he's created
not only for himself but his state
interest
while we
don't have a legal
written
testimony someplace about father's
rights
this is a derived right out of natural
law
and the way our culture works in caring
for
children and raising them properly
and other aspects of law
will come into play
if that obligation is not fulfilled
but this one
focuses on
the right of the father to have a say to
have a participation and so
i'm asking you to please vote or to pass
on hb 1181
thank you representative are there any
questions for representative stapleton
representative horrigan
thank you very much mr chair thank you
mr representative stapleton um
obviously once the child is born the
relationship between the parents will be
somewhat different than it usually is so
does this bill do anything
and so even after the child obviously
once a child is born he or she is no
longer an unborn child so you know the
state's interest in it is different but
there's still a valid state interest so
what what does this do to make sure that
uh
that the
child is uh properly cared for that the
father and the mother meet their
i'm having difficulty my hearing aids
are low on battery and okay i'm having
trouble discerning your quote
once
in due course if you prevent the mother
having abortion the unborn child will
eventually become a born child and the
state
will still have a valid interest maybe a
different interest than while the child
is unborn so what does does this bill do
anything in order to
make sure that
what happens after the child is born
is is
that the child is properly cared for
after
in
if the injunction is granted for uh
stopping the abortion on the father's
appeal to the court
uh and as and it's successful the second
part of the bill talks about uh the
incurring of cost and responsibility for
costs and expenses
um
but again the this the bill has a narrow
focus here and it does not extend into
the life of the child
going forward
other sections of law
and our culture and customs
apply
for care of the child once born
that child has rights
under the 14th amendment among others
and the way we are as a culture and a
people we we take care of our children
and if the state has to step in because
that's not happening
you know we have provisions and statutes
and
law to
make sure that that child is protected i
mean that's what family court is
supposed to do are there are there other
questions for representative stapleton
representative chase did you have a
question
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
i i understand the concept of what
you're trying to do in giving dad's
rights but it just doesn't seem like
it's fully completed i don't see
anywhere again as
representative smith was saying that
this has anything to do with the mom
actually almost like an adoption giving
over the rights of her child and not
being involved in the children the
child's upbringing
if you're trying to strictly do this to
forefathers to be able to take
their child that the mom may not want
it it just doesn't seem to have all of
the the information that's needed
um also and you've got in here about you
know
the
line 23 on page four the mama requests
the court
to issue a restraining order against the
father whatever conditions the court
judge seems appropriate
why would a mother have to put a
restraining order against a father and
then feel that that father was capable
to raise their child or a child doesn't
even matter if she doesn't want it
that's a violent person
yes where are all these parts
for
yeah
i i think i know where you're going with
that i'm having trouble hearing but i
think i got the gist of it um
the bill doesn't prevent cooperation
after
in the case of an injunction and a
abortion is prohibited
um this bill doesn't prevent cooperation
of those parents
who when a child is born now become
responsible
and just like if there was an
uncontested
birth and in a normal fashion where
people got together and
got married and had children
again this bill is a narrow focus
because we haven't recognized the rights
of the father to participate in this
question
and
you know if you wanted to extend the
responsibilities and duties that we
would have a bill that contained volumes
instead of focused on the right of the
father to participate in the transaction
once again
when that child is born a child has
rights under the constitution as an
individual
and there are obligations for those
parents or that parent if there's only
one involved
to make sure that child is cared for
in a safe and
in a good manner okay
thank you
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question representative
stapleton
um you've used the term transaction a
couple of times and i'm wondering if you
could
tell me what which piece of this is the
transaction i'm not sure
what you're referring to
adoption would be
a most desirable thing in the case that
the parents
in this action were not capable
or not willing
adoptions happen all the time and there
are so many people out there that are
looking for child
for children they can't have their own
so adoption is an avenue for
those parents to have and enjoy and
raise a child as well as to relieve the
obligation for
the people who did not maybe intend to
have a child or did not want to have a
child but through the natural occurrence
pregnancy occurs
but regardless of how the pregnancy
occurs by will
or by accident
um
that that life that's human life in the
womb
and okay there may be a day when that
human life is declared right to life
from the moment of conception there are
several bills
that have been furthered in the federal
system
life at conception act
now we don't know when that might occur
or if it's going to occur
but um
we have to honor
human life
and
that's from
before birth during birth and then after
birth and
again if we were to expound on every
obligation that's already established in
culture and law we'd have volumes in
this bill instead of three pages
thank you representative stapleton
representatives
yeah three minutes
thank you mr chairman i appreciate you
getting me up here and thank you my
colleagues for hearing me today
i am
here to represent the
father
as well as the unborn child
i was married
for
a couple of years got pregnant by my
husband
and decided i didn't want to be stuck
with that
and i want to get rid of that product of
conception which as we now know would
have been a baby and that baby would
have been 33 years old this year
and i regret it every day
came to me and said
cause i told him
and i told him i was gonna abort the
he said please let me have the baby and
i will raise the baby and you don't have
to have any
dealings with me or the baby
but i was selfish
and i made a horrible decision
it was the worst decision i've ever made
in my entire life
i regretted to this day
it's
it was
terrible what i did
he had every right as the father of that
child
to have that child
to raise that child to have that child
in his life
whether i chose to have that child in my
life or not
it was wrong of me
he had rights
and i told him you don't have any rights
it's my body and i'm going to do with it
what i want well guess what
somebody else's body
i had removed
somebody else i had taken ripped out of
me
and that was also another little story
i'll be telling you guys about later
but that father
had the right
to have to be a father to that child
that i killed and i just want you to
know that had i listened to him and had
he had the right to stop me i may things
might have been different i might have
had a chance to rethink it maybe we
would have had an agreement at that
point but no
no
it was wrong
the father has rights and i i'm here in
support of this bill thank you for
hearing me and i have to go
mr chairman members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to testify
today my name is frank knack i'm the
policy director with the aclu of new
hampshire
and we are here in strong opposition to
this bill
um you know we've talked a lot about
about uh you know what this bill could
and couldn't do there's been some great
questions from members i'd just like to
you know dig in and get away from the
theory and talk about what this bill
would look like in practice
in practice this legislation means that
survivors of abusive relationships could
have their abortion blocked by their
abuser
under this bill a victim of incest would
bear the burden of costs to have dna
testing to show that it was in fact
incest
this legislation you know as we all know
we've talked about abortion is safe
legal medical procedure it is legal in
new hampshire up to 24 weeks
this legislation would criminalize
people for seeking a constitutionally
protected medical procedure
under this bill injunction could be
they the way it would work is basically
anyone could claim paternity there's a
temporary injunction put on the person
within the pregnant person would not
have the ability to exercise their
constitutional right to abortion a safe
legal medical procedure
because one person made a claim and then
if that person's claim turns out to be
false under this bill there is zero
penalty for bringing a false claim
in addition i think as we just heard one
of the co-sponsors of the bill
i think this the intent of this bill is
crystal clear it's a backdoor attempt to
further restrict the fundamental right
to abortion in new hampshire you know as
of january 1 of this year new hampshire
had been one of the states where you
know the fundamental right to abortion
was something that we all value
as as granite staters and as of january
1st of this year uh there's a parental
consent law there's restrictions on
funding there's a 24-week ban there is a
mandatory ultrasound law this bill would
be yet another attempt to further
restrict the fundamental right to
abortion in new hampshire
and we think that's that's deeply
problematic
in addition i think the initial sponsor
of the bill talked about this bill as
something that protects safety and i
think again the facts don't bear that
out
so what this bill would do would be to
potentially delay someone seeking an
abortion uh if they're seeking it for
some type of medical reason that would
then be delayed and further further put
the jeopardize the the pregnant person's
uh health in that situation so again
i think the the claims made by
proponents are
quite transparent what they're actually
attempting to do and i urge this
committee to oppose this bill thank you
thank you are there any questions for mr
knack
attorney knack
i have 10 people who have signed up i
have 10 cards for people who have signed
up
and
and all of the remaining cards are
speaking in opposition to the bill so
i've indicated they intend to speak in
opposition
hello um thank you for taking me uh my
testimony um my name is sarah smith
i live in pembroke new hampshire
i'm in opposition to this deeply flawed
bill
that has many um
misconceptions about the way the world
a man came in through my window
put his hand on my neck
and then
i had to face the the consequences of
that
let me tell you the first thing
that a person who's been raped thinks
about is whether that person
will come back
again
this bill
makes that nightmare
there's no
there's no way that somebody who has
been raped
should have to face
this situation without being able to
deal with it
on her own
terms
not file a petition
in addition the other deeply flawed part
of this bill
is that
it gives
all the weight to the father
there is nothing in this bill that says
that you will consider anything that the
woman wants
in this petition
this bill
just reminds me of the nightmare that i
live every night
for the last 40 some years
and it cannot be voted into law
i'm sorry if i've repeated anything
before but
the sound in this i i am extremely hard
of hearing if you have any questions
please speak close slowly and clearly
seeing none thank you
hello my name is josie pinto and i'm the
founder and executive director of the
reproductive freedom fund of new
hampshire we're an organization working
to reduce barriers to abortion access
for all granite staters through direct
funding of abortion care providing
logistical support and providing
information and education relating to
reproductive health
i'm here to express my strong opposition
to hb 1181
when i first read this bill i was
horrified i felt sick
to think that there is any possibility
that someone other than a pregnant
person could be more entitled to what
happens to their own body would be
setting the most harmful legal precedent
i can imagine
it would open up the gates to more
legislation that further strips us from
access to making decisions about our own
bodies the decision to terminate a
pregnancy should always be up to the
person who is pregnant and anything less
than that is utter cruelty
as someone who works every single day to
break down barriers to abortion access
let me tell you there are plenty of
barriers in place already
between the cost of the procedure
needing transportation taking time off
work and securing child care
more than half of abortion parents are
already parents already
it can be incredibly difficult for
people to access abortion care
legislation like hb 1181 adds
unnecessary and morally egregious
hurdles to care that is already so
difficult to access this bill wouldn't
even require proof that the person suing
is the father
only if the pregnant person denies
paternity would a dna test be required
meaning anyone could initiate a lawsuit
and slow down the process for obtaining
an abortion as i read this bill i was
shocked to see that a pregnant person
misses their court date the injunction
prohibiting them from obtaining an
abortion is automatically granted
this is a blatant denial of due process
for pregnant people and a
major civil rights and human rights
violation
there can be so many barriers to
responding to court summons and the
court process would significantly stall
someone from accessing abortion in a
timely manner abortion is a time
sensitive issue the longer a patient has
to wait for an abortion the more it
costs and the more difficult accessing
it becomes not to mention this bill
wouldn't even require the pregnant
person to live in new hampshire but
would still force them to travel here
and if they already had had the abortion
and the injunction gets granted the
court could hold them in civil or
criminal contempt even though they did
nothing illegal
none of this is okay the strategy here
is clear create as many barriers to
access as possible to delay care and
then ban abortion later in pregnancy
the bill would enshrine in law
patriarchal violence and reduce pregnant
people in new hampshire to mere vessels
with little to no civil rights for this
reason and so many others we strongly
urge the committee to recommend this
bill as inexpedient to legislate and
affirm the civil rights and bodily
autonomy of pregnant people in new
hampshire thank you
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
good morning representative mary heck
and phillips grafton county district 12
representing the folks from hanover and
lime
i prepared a few remarks today but i'm
going to strike those from my testimony
i'd just like to respond to this simple
idea that has been presented by the
built sponsors
that
know
that it is not established in law
that the father should have any rights
in the abortion decision
i stand before you as a person holding a
law degree as a member of the new
hampshire bar association to say that
in fact
the law of the land since 1973
has said that there is a fundamental
right to choose without
excessive government interference in
that decision and
and since 1976 united states supreme
court decided in planned parenthood
of missouri versus danforth that exact
balancing act between a father's rights
and a
and a pregnant person's rights to make
the court held
in that danforth case that spousal
consent or in this case a partner's
consent
for a pregnant person to seek an
abortion does not comport with the
standards enunciated in a row versus
wade
and that a state cannot delegate to a
spouse the veto power which the state
itself is absolutely and totally
prohibited
from exercising during the first try
man's trimester of pregnancy
the court reasoned that a woman's right
to privacy in her medical decisions must
be a paramount and must be paramount to
that of her spouse or partner
and also the simple fact that the
pregnant person is more directly
affected by that pregnancy clearly the
court stated both prospective parents
have an interest in the decision
but when the two disagree on the matter
of abortion only one partner's position
can prevail
that of the pregnant person
because the balance weighs in their
favor
preventing the potential father in this
case or husband from vetoing the choice
this bill has extreme implications
causes and begs the question what other
health care decisions will require a
spouse or partner's consent
deeply deeply concerning thoughts here
what other private decisions of new
hampshire citizens may the state
override as well
i think these are very dark
hypotheticals and
you know there is current and
well-established law that speaks to this
balancing act that the sponsors have
misinterpreted as a member of the bar i
urge you to seek legal counsel
and if you don't please be able 15
seconds please be advised
can you wrap up your testimony i am
that litigation will follow it will be
very costly for the state
and in addition to the current ongoing
litigation the state is okay paying for
it this will follow
and it will not be easy to
to um fold into the um
current legislative um doctrine thank
you
thank you for your testimony
are there any questions for the
representative
seeing none
the next person to testify
and i hope i can do this well as sophia
thank you chairman gordon and members of
the committee for taking my testimony
today
for the record my name is sophia
biandalilo i'm 15. i'm from manchester
and i'm speaking today on behalf of the
new hampshire high school democrats
i submitted my testimony via the remote
sign in ahead of the hearing and i also
have a physical copy
so yeah
the new hampshire high school democrats
urged the committee to recommend that hb
1181 be inexpedient to legislate um
outside of the issue of abortion there
are quite a few issues of this
legislation that make it ill-advised
regardless of what stance members of
this committee might otherwise have on
abortion in general
hb 1181 would put several barriers in
place
through long and complicated legal
obligations which would make attaining
justice
essentially impossible for a pregnant
person this would enable as some others
have already discussed
an abusive partner to force a pregnant
person to undergo a painful and unwanted
pregnancy for at least 24 weeks against
their will even if the court ultimately
decides that terminating that pregnancy
would have been appropriate in the first
place it's important to consider or
think about this bill the reality of the
new hampshire family court system and
the court system in general
family courts are constantly overwhelmed
and after filing a complaint with the
court it's likely that a petitioner
would have to wait several months for a
hearing in any other case
and if mediation is required that
usually is additional months onto the
timeline and then dna testing is
obviously another possible delay um and
again i just want to reiterate that even
though there is a deadline of 24 weeks
meeting that deadline is probably not
very practical because of the delays in
the court system already
and the pregnant person is still forced
to carry that fetus for at least 24
weeks even if the decision is made in
that timeline and then on top of that if
the decision is made in 23 or 24 weeks
the pregnant person would still have to
schedule an appointment to actually
receive services which usually involves
consultation and a number of other
appointments which might push them past
the deadline even if the decision is
made within 23 weeks so it still might
be an abortion ban
in general um
and then in addition obtaining legal
services and continuing to pay for them
over the course of the proceedings um
would be an undue burden on somebody who
is most likely already struggling
financially if they are seriously
considering terminating their pregnancy
and i don't believe this bill requires
the petitioner to pay for those services
legal services
um
and although some people
some previous speakers have stated that
the father carries all responsibility
for the pregnancy if the injunction is
granted they don't have to give birth
they don't have to pay as far as bill
states
for the tens of thousands of dollars it
sometimes costs
to actually deliver a baby in an
emergency room or hospital and also
there is evidence that being forced to
carry a child or a fetus
that somebody doesn't want can have
lasting effects on their mental health
for the rest of their life including um
higher rates of eviction higher rates of
poverty higher rates of depression and
so even if the father does take
responsibility after birth there's still
15 seconds sorry for the mother years
into the future after that um also
sorry just wrap up if you yeah yeah um
the legislature basically by passing
this bill would be um taking power away
from the courts and forcing them to
sorry
passing this bill would probably take
power away from the courts because of
the various delays that it would impose
and it would lead to outcomes that would
be against the judge's best interests so
the new hampshire high school democrats
would urge the committee to recover
recommend hb1181 being expedient
allegedly thank you ms mandellio
are there any questions from his
vandalia
seeing none thank you for your testimony
good morning my name is liz canada i'm
the advocacy manager at planned
parenthood new hampshire action fund and
planned parenthood of northern new
england we oppose house bill 1181 house
bill 1181 is an outrageous and offensive
bill meant to shame burden and degrade
women seeking abortion care it is
insulting and a danger to women
particularly those in abusive
relationships
in house bill 1181 any man without
needing to prove paternity could file a
petition with the court which would
immediately stop a woman from being able
to have an abortion
a court hearing would be scheduled up to
two weeks later
and if the woman lives out of state
which this bill allows
she would need to be physically present
in the courthouse for that hearing or
else somehow the state of new hampshire
would be able to prohibit her from
having an abortion
it is unclear in this bill as to how the
state of new hampshire would be able to
do that
at the hearing two weeks later then the
woman can say this person is not the
father
and then there would be required dna
testing
to be clear dna testing for parental
origin of a fetus cannot happen before
nine weeks of pregnancy
so under this bill medication abortion
which can only happen until the 11th
week of pregnancy would be essentially
banned for women in new hampshire
because this legal process could not
resolve before the 11th week
between the hearing and the tests and
the testing the legal process alone
would delay a woman's constitutionally
protected right to safe legal abortion
by a month i'll remind the committee
that abortion care becomes less
accessible the longer it is delayed
if the pregnancy is a result of rape the
woman would have already needed to
report the rape before her rapist goes
to court to file a petition to stop her
from having an abortion and if the
pregnancy is a result of incest the
financial burden of obtaining dna proof
falls on her
this bill is a blatantly sexist attack
on women
allowing a woman's body to be controlled
by an abusive partner by the judicial
system and by the legislature
as granite staters we aren't actually
free if we can't make our own decisions
about our own bodies lives and futures
whether that is saying no to unwanted
sexual advances
no to an unintended pregnancy or yes to
becoming a parent the decision about
whether and when to become a parent is
one of the most important life decisions
we make when people can make decisions
that are best for their lives families
thrive and we build communities where
each of us can participate with dignity
and equality women deserve to make these
decisions for themselves with influence
from their loved ones and health care
providers our state should not allow
judges rapists sexual partners or anyone
to make these decisions for women this
bill is an extreme attack on abortion
and bodily 15 seconds and it has no
place in the legislature we urge you to
vote in expedient to legislate thank you
thank you any questions for miss canada
lorelei
godfrey
good morning chair gordon and members of
the committee thank you so much for
hearing my testimony this morning
my name is laura lee godfrey and i'm 17
years old from portsmouth new hampshire
and i come before you today in
opposition to hb 1181
allowing the biological father of an
unborn child to petition the court for
an injunction
my primary objection to this bill stems
from the fact that it flagrantly
dismisses a woman's bodily autonomy
this bill would legally force women to
hold on to unwanted pregnancies and that
is a violation of a woman's
constitutionally protected personal
rights
previous speakers have said that this
bill is meant to give men a right in
this process while still weighing
relatively a woman's right higher
but this bill in filing an injunction
goes against the woman's decision and
holds the father's right to a greater
weight so if you believe these previous
speaker's sentiments you have to itl
this bill
this bill attempts to set an efficient
time frame under which the father's
petition must be addressed but there is
no guarantee that it will be followed in
fact it's probably more likely than not
that this would be the case
in new hampshire we are already
experiencing an extreme case backlog and
judge shortage and abortion is a time
sensitive issue
fetuses don't wait for a court tape to
become viable and as a result anyone who
claims paternity could then have the
power to decide a woman's pregnancy
in the event an injunction is granted if
the pregnancy poses an imminent threat
to the life of the pregnant person an
appeal still has to go through the judge
which could then cause dangerous delays
in their health care
this bill is gambling against
bureaucracy with the health and safety
of pregnant new hampshire citizens
to give men rights over a body that
isn't theirs
genetics teaches us that sexual
reproduction results in a baby that ends
up possessing 50 percent of the father's
genetics and 50 of the mothers
but this bill ignores that that fetus is
a hundred percent only being delivered
abortion is already a stressful costly
and incredibly personal decision in of
itself
the bill language specification
highlighting how a pregnant person must
attend all medical appointments to
ensure a safe and healthy pregnancy in
the case an injunction is granted places
further scrutiny on pregnant individuals
in spite of potential health
complications that could arise
if they suffer a pregnancy a pregnancy
loss later down the road this bill
creates an implication that unless the
pregnant person did everything they
could to save the pregnancy they are at
risk of violating the injunction
subsequently we see that hb 1181
blatantly disregards maternal health at
all costs
and finally this bill ignores the
traumatic backgrounds that can influence
pregnant individuals to seek abortions
in the first place victims of domestic
and sexual abuse should not have their
privacy 15 seconds state government and
this bill would only enable their
abusers
all hb 1181 is trying to do is control
women if you vote to pass this bill you
would be voting to explicitly hurt women
i urge you to vote itl thank you
thank you for your testimony are there
seeing none thank you
ogie young
good morning
good morning thank you mr chairman and
thank you judiciary committee for
the work you do
and thank you for allowing us to speak
my name is dr ogyum
i practiced obstetrics and gynecology
for almost 40 years
in concord i'm a past president of
the new hampshire medical society
and i remain on their general counsel
representing
all the obstetricians
in new hampshire
i've been around a long time
and
i don't think i've ever seen a more
ludicrous
anti-abortion bill
this law
to claim to be
the father of a pregnancy
prior to any scientific
evidence of paternity
that means that any of us males in this
room
could claim
fatherhood
in another woman's pregnancy and without
penalty
this bill has no penalty for that claim
if it's not true
practically speaking this law would
delay
a woman's termination
up to over a month
making it impossible to do the
termination early in pregnancy when it's
safest when it can be done medically
when it can be done
early with a small uterus that's easily
easy to empty i wish i could show each
of you the difference between
terminating a pregnancy at six to eight
weeks
versus 12 to 14 weeks
this law would put
women
a woman's health at risk
if a woman is choosing to terminate her
pregnancy she obviously conceived
against her will
where is the responsibility of the male
who didn't use any birth control
in fact to the extreme it could be a
male
who raped her
and yet he's still given the right
to stop her abortion delay her
abortion
come on
this bill is absolutely ridiculous
it's creating an obstacle
making a woman's personal decision
at the bequest of an irresponsible male
a male who doesn't carry the pregnancy a
male who doesn't deliver
the baby
and very frequently doesn't support the
mom and baby
after the birth
if we are so concerned about males
rights
we should also have a bill
that
would allow the biologic
father to petition
the court 15 seconds to require
a pregnant woman have an abortion
that bill obviously doctor if you could
wrap up your testimony would be no more
outrageous than 1181 i cannot imagine
any of you
not opposing this bill
thank you
none thank you for your testimony
today i have two more people who have
thank you chairman
thank you for letting me speak and
i think it's important we take note of
where we are as a state and as a country
it is getting harder to make ends meet
how do we properly
how do we raise children properly
when we as a country
don't provide paid parental leave
health care is not affordable in this
country
welfare is extremely frowned upon
yet we're living in a state that hasn't
raised minimum wage in 13 years
or that's yeah that's under half my life
but you get it
the cost of living has been exponential
we don't support affordable college
we don't have affordable housing
this is all correlated to raising a
child in a healthy environment
if i were to get pregnant
if i were to be placed in this position
i could not provide the best quality of
i think this is a shared decision meant
for the woman and the male not the
governments
there are hundreds of thousands of kids
i think it is also worthwhile to point
out that there can be life-threatening
health complications with some
pregnancies that could endanger the
like others said where is the woman's
women have just recently gained equal
rights
women used to not be able to open their
own bank account
and as others pointed out
is there any obligation for the father
to stay in the picture after birth
if this bill passes
then so should universal health care
child care and tuition free college
that would be a start that would be
pro-life
thank you very much for your time
thank you any questions from his
seeing them thank you for your testimony
today thank you
and the last card i have is for
ameristolin
thank you chair gordon thank you to
members of the judiciary committee for
hearing me today my name is maris
tolland i'm a resident physician in
obstetrics and gynecology
specializing in reproductive health i'm
also a resident of new hampshire
this bill makes me sick to my stomach
as a physician in women's health who
sees these issues every day the first
fear that evokes for me is that of
intimate partner violence
i'd like you to ponder a hypothetical
scenario
a 13 year old is sexually and physically
abused by her father she becomes
pregnant but she doesn't find out until
she's 10 weeks along
or maybe 14 weeks along or maybe 21
weeks along
periods can be pretty irregular when
you're pre-menopausal or pre-adolescent
her mother finds out she removes her
from the home
they make the challenging decision to
seek an abortion
but the biological father also her
abuser petitions the court to stop her i
understand that this bill makes a point
of denying injunctions in the case of
incest but due to waiting for delays in
the court verifying dna testing which
can occur before nine weeks of pregnancy
and routine delays because of short
staffing in our state
she progresses far enough in pregnancy
that she no longer has the resources or
potentially the legal option to undergo
this procedure
here's another scenario
25 year old she's in an increasingly
abusive marriage the last time she
became pregnant
with her husband she miscarried because
he beat her
she didn't report it to the police
because she was afraid so he doesn't
have a promoting record she's trying to
save up enough money to leave him and
she finds out she's pregnant again she
doesn't want to tie
uh have this pregnancy tired to her
husband because when she was pregnant
the last time he threatened to kill her
did you know that the number one cause
of death in pregnant women his homicide
she makes the difficult choice to have
an abortion but her husband finds out
and petitions the court she know that he
this bill is about control as others
have said specifically a man's ability
to control a woman's body
the idea that any man
could petition the court to be able to
prohibit a person from
achieving
safe and essential medical services
is appalling
i don't feel like i need to reiterate
the eloquent testimony that others have
given today
but i just want to add my voice to say
that this bill limits access to a safe
and an essential medical service and it
sends a very dangerous and a very sexist
and oppressive message about our state
this should be opposed
thank you for listening to me
any questions for the doctor
sigmund thank you for your testimony
today
is there anyone who hasn't spoken who
seeing no one we will close the hearing
and we will open the hearing on house
bill
1477 this is an act prohibiting
abortions after detection of a fetal
heartbeat
and i will call upon the prime sponsor
representative testament to provide his
testimony again my intention would be to
give the sponsors of the bill five
minutes and then everyone else three
minutes and speaking here today
i do have
quite a number of cards
representative testament thank you
my name is for the record my name is
dave testerman i'm a representative from
and i'm here today to introduce
a bill fairly simple
on the field on when
you can't have an abortion
1477.
we have a lot of
bills that have been
put forth
that are somewhat complicated
this one takes a
stethoscope to determine whether or not
there's a heartbeat
i would rather see a bill
that was
at conception
i wasn't really happy with 24 weeks or
whatever you want to pick it
i
would like to keep
they
it's not really a pro-life bill it's an
anti-pro-death bill
i i believe that we need
to to have a bill
that clearly states
we do not approve of murder in the womb
thank you
the questions representative smith
thank you very much for
taking my question this morning
um can you
i'm i'm not a doctor and i don't pretend
to be i'm a legislator and i try to keep
out of
medical decisions
um but in your research leading up to
this bill can you tell me at what stage
a fetus can survive outside of the
uterus and whether that bears any
relation
to
what might be considered to be a fetal
heartbeat
i mean i don't believe that has anything
to do
with this bill this bill isn't about
viability or anything else i don't know
what that is i'm an engineer
it's thank you very much for your candor
i appreciate it
represent mclean
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question are you aware of any
states that have similar legislation
like this on the books right now
i believe that there is one in texas
that uh has some version of this
uh there are
other states four or five i don't know
what they what which states they are but
i know texas there's a
bill that is sitting in front of the
any other questions for representative
testerman
cnn thank you representative thank you
representative stapleton i see you are a
co-sponsor was it your intention to
speak
thank you mr chair members of the
committee i'm walt stapleton i am the
third ward clermont rep
sullivan county district five and i am a
co-sponsor and supporter
of h.b 1477
the
protection of life after detection of
why not
24 weeks efficient
as we
i've heard and read that
most abortions occur in the first and
second trimester
so this bill is intended to afford
protections to those
early life
and
it's linked of course to the detection
of heartbeat
the fetus the young baby is
coming to life
and
there have been over
centuries various measures of
how we
the old term quicken for instance
but we have scientific methods now we
have the wonderful
instrument of ultrasound which can take
a
inside look see
at
how the the baby is doing in the womb
detect problems
detect
malformations
and so we can actually take a peek
inside the womb
and appreciate the life that is resident
there
living and growing
and hopefully to be destined to become
a live person
born
with all the rights that you and i enjoy
and all the privileges
and all of the opportunities that life
is
about those of us who
acknowledge the providence of a
creator
understand that the process of life in
the womb is necessary for
our culture and our populations to grow
and to flourish
to cut that life off prematurely
is to deny those opportunities that
individual
opportunity for that child to
grow and
be fulfilled
in life and it's
many aspects just like we all here
today are enjoying because
our mothers and fathers
protected
the life in the womb
it has a certain sanctity
so
we feel that the marker of the heartbeat
is at least a good
point at which
to effect that early protection
and so
we we would like to see that
happen
and there are other states that have
done similar initiatives
for eight weeks maybe even six weeks and
some at 15 weeks and
some at 20 weeks
pain-capable act for instance is one
but
we we prefer in the writing of this bill
to afford early protection as much as
possible we feel the eighth
week with the heartbeat
is a valid
and reasonable
marker for that protection and so i ask
you to support
1477 is ought to pass
thank you and are there any questions
xenon thanks for your testimony thank
you mr chair
and that i don't see any other sponsors
of the bill here so we'll
move on
again and restrict testimony to three
minutes
per person representative hawkins
phillips
representative hackens from grafton
county district 12. i rise in opposition
to this bill hb 1477 for primarily three
reasons
first the premises of this bill is
faulty
on behalf of the reproductive health
medical experts like the dhmc ob gyns
who live in my district
the definition of fetal heartbeat in the
proposed ball uh bill
is misleading
instead what we're talking about is the
detection of a group of cells that are
initiating some electrical activity
in no way is this detecting a functional
cardiovascular system
or a functional heartbeat
at six weeks of gestation when this
electrical activity can be detected by
ultrasound no heart valves are in
existence in the embryo
this flickering can be detected by an
ultrasound machine at this early stage
of development in pregnancy
but this electrical activity
is only that
the term fetal heartbeat is not a
medical term of art or is
and it is not used practically in the
practice of medicine
instead this term is a political tool to
further suppress a pregnant person's
fundamental right to seek abortion care
second criminalization in this bill of
health care providers who perform an
abortion after approximately six weeks
of gestation is an extreme interference
by the state as an insulting to the
professionals who make great sacrifices
to serve their communities
it will further disincentivize the best
and brightest physicians from practicing
obstetrics and gynecology in new
hampshire and it will create a health
care crisis in the state for those who
seek other ob gyn health care needs and
services
it puts the health care of women girls
and pregnant people of this state at
severe risk
third it's politically inexpedient new
hampshire will join the infamous ranks
of texas and alabama estates that do not
recognize women and pregnant people as
fully autonomous humans this bill
will
attract an unwanted media attention to
our state and let all americans know
that the live free or die motto is not
for the women girls or pregnant people
of new hampshire thank you
seeing them thank you for your testimony
today
thank you mr chairman and thank you
committee members
my baby
i think
i think i knew i was pregnant pretty
much right away
and then of course
the signs that you're pregnant were
there
and
it was tested and and then
proven that i was
by the time i found out and had made the
decision to murder my baby and take the
life of my baby and kill that
person the baby was probably
maybe eight weeks and that was a beating
heart
i want you all to know how difficult
this is
because i still suffered like right now
from that horrendous decision decision
and and i do want to make clear
the only people who get pregnant are
women
the greatest sacrifice people are
talking about sacrificing their lives i
was i was selfish
so i didn't want to sacrifice my way of
living the way i had my life going i
didn't want to sacrifice that so i
sacrificed i blood sacrificed my baby
i killed
that
other
person
i had no right to take that baby's life
and i had no right to steal that baby
from my husband and i had no right to
steal that baby from my family
my mother just passed away in december
i had to go away
and take a little retreat
and as i walked
on the beach where i went
i thought about how
i had stolen
that life
from my family
not only from that baby
but from my family and from the father
of that baby whether i am in touch with
him now or not
and i want you to know that i don't want
any of my federally
federal taxes not one
penny
going
to fund
the
cessation
of a beating heart
that is a person
it's a person
it's not a product
of conception
it's a baby and a person
and it has different fingerprints
different hair color different eye color
it's not
me
that baby was not 15 seconds i'm sorry
i'm gonna i'll wrap it up i'm sorry yep
please remember mr chairman
this is this is a very uh close to my
heart subject so anyway i will say i do
agree with this i i support this bill
and please let's not stop any more
beating hearts thank you
thank you
micah virich
hello my name is dr michael ulrich i
thank you all for allowing me the
opportunity to speak here today
um on behalf of myself i'm a resident
physician
in the state of new hampshire practicing
obstetrics and gynecology i'm currently
completing my training as we speak
i'm speaking in strong opposition to
house bill 1477
i'm honored every day by the opportunity
to provide reproductive health care for
the people in the state of new hampshire
that is why i'm here to speak with you
all today because of the
because the ability for physicians such
as myself to continue to provide
fundamental health care for the people
in the state is being threatened by
house bill 1477.
as we have already heard today house
bill 1477 intends to prohibit abortion
after detection of a fetal heart rate
which can be as early as six weeks of
gestation
this is less than a month after a woman
misses her menstrual period
what we know from cdc data published in
2019 is that the large majority of
abortions in this country are performed
at what is considered an early gestation
which is defined as less than 13 weeks
of gestation
looking closer at these numbers
only 40 percent of those are performed
at less than six weeks gestation what
these numbers tell us is simple
the majority of persons needing access
to abortion services do not and likely
cannot present to care before six weeks
gestational age cut off
passing this bill makes no impact on the
reasons a person may need an abortion
be it financial restrictions preventing
them from caring for an additional child
or threats to their own health care by
continuing the pregnancy it does not fix
sometimes severe prognoses of fetuses
affected by conditions that may not be
diagnosed until later in pregnancy
it cannot stop the cases of sexual
assault that result in unintended
pregnancies it does not fix
contraceptive failure
instead this bill makes time
makes time of the essence it gives
people six weeks six weeks at best if
they even know they were pregnant six
weeks to make sometimes a very very
difficult choice and if this choice
cannot be made before six weeks it
completely takes that choice away
this bill will not stop people from
needing essential sometimes life-saving
abortion services
people deserve access to the health care
that they need and they deserve it in
the state of new hampshire please oppose
bill 1477.
thank you for your testimony are there
any questions for the doctor
good morning
and
thank you very much for allowing me to
speak my name is karen testerman and i
am a citizen of the state of new
hampshire and i am domiciled in the city
when you took office
you swore an oath to support the state
of new hampshire's constitution
words have meaning and this is why
elected officials are required to take
that oath when they assume their office
it's therefore my belief that your words
are truthful and valuable
and to be trusted until you prove
otherwise
part 1 article 2
states that all men have certain natural
essential and inherent rights among
which are defending life
which is why i stand before you today to
support the heartbeat as the audible
sign of life
the heart is the organ that medical
practitioners use as a sign of the
existence of life
therefore it is logical that the
presence of a heartbeat is a sign of
life you have sworn to defend
please consider the following
representative green
is shorter than representative weckler
does that mean that
representative green's life is any more
valuable than that of representative
webler
the preborn is smaller in size than
either
of
the representatives
if it would be a crime to murder
representative greene
because he is shorter than
representative wesler
it stands to reason that we should not
allow the murder of the preborn because
he she is smaller the preborn is less
developed than the born human being
does this disqualify the life from being
defended
sorry
uh cannot bear children
because her reproductive system is less
developed than a 20 year old woman
the life of the four-year-old is still
as valuable as a child bearing young
woman the preborn is less developed than
a four-year-old therefore we cannot
disqualify the lives of the
four-year-old or the pre-born from
defending because they are less
developed than the older more developed
humans
the pre-born is located in a different
environment than a born human does your
location affect your value
if you are a scuba diver in the depths
of the water
um is your life any more valuable than
that of the pilots flying the airplane
or the motorcyclists on the roads of new
hampshire
if any of these humans were in a
life-threatening situation we would go
to great lengths to save any one of them
if changing your environment can't
change your value how can a seven inch
journey through the birth canal
magically train 15 seconds
human into any one value
uh because of the location
representative this is just a second
this is life
it's just as is to be defended as well
the preborn is dependent upon her his
mother's body for nutrition and a proper
environment for development if you are
the only adult present when a toddler
falls into a swimming pool are you
justified in declaring her of no value
because she is dependent upon you for
survival
each i will be done in just
minute is dependent upon someone else
each one
for a life-sustaining measure
at some point in our lives depending
upon another does not disqualify the
value of your life
neither does the dependency of the
preborn disqualify him from being
defended
for survival every life has value no
matter their size location environment
or dependency
the heartbeat i'm got one sentence left
the heartbeat
is a universal scientific
non-controversial sign of life therefore
i ask that you uphold your oath of
office to support the supreme state of
new hampshire's constitution in
defending life vote hb 1477
ought to pass
thank you do you have any questions
thank you any questions from his tester
good morning honorable members of the
judiciary committee my name is caleb
montgomery i'm the vice president of
public affairs for planned parenthood
new hampshire action fund and planned
parenthood of northern new england just
make sure you speak into the microphones
sure and understand what you're saying
is that better
we strongly oppose this bill it is a
near total ban on abortion in the state
of new hampshire just two quick points
for you today
firstly supporters of this bill may
argue that a pregnant person would still
have six weeks to decide if they wanted
to have an abortion
this is simply not true and reveals a
real lack of understanding of the
reproductive system
as people who have been pregnant know in
order for doctors to have a consistent
way to estimate the length of pregnancy
we use the first day of the last
menstruation period
as day one of pregnancy
even though there is no pregnancy for
the first two weeks or so so for those
with a regular menstruation cycle this
bill would stop access to safe legal
abortion after only a few days after a
missed period
secondly
we do not have to imagine a world where
abortion is bans to see the real life
consequences of this legislation
texas has had a near total ban on
abortion in effect since september 1st
in texas the combination of people not
knowing they are pregnant at six weeks
and other factors like navigating
unnecessary restrictions like a 24-hour
mandatory delay and raising the funds
for an abortion has made it impossible
to get abortion care in texas for far
too many people
those who do have the means to travel
out of state
are being met with overloaded health
centers at the border states
this creates a domino effect leading to
border
state residents being forced to endure
long delays in care and in some
instances because of the decreased
availability of appointments than also
being forced out of care
ultimately this is creating chaos for
individual patients and for the region
house bill 1477 would push granite
staters out of state to get care if they
can afford it
sending patients out of state is
completely unnecessary abortion
providers have been operating safely in
the state for decades
this bill will not provide any benefit
to patients it will only cause harm
so abortion bans like this one are
unconstitutional
disproportionately impact low-income and
marginalized people are deeply unpopular
and are an extreme attack on abortion
rights and we urge you to oppose this
bill thank you
any questions from his montgomery
sign then thank you for your testimony
today
good morning chairman and members of the
judiciary community and thank you for
the opportunity to be here today
my name is mariah mccarron i am new
england regional coordinator with
students for life action students for
life action a 501c4 along with its 501c3
sister organization
students for life of america make up the
nation's largest pro-life youth
organization and a political and policy
operation engaging people of all ages
together they work to end abortion the
human rights issue of our day and
provide political legal and community
support for women and their children
both born and pre-born sfla has more
than 1 250 groups in middle high school
college
university medical and law school
campuses in all 50 states i'm joined by
a few of my students here today
i stand before you
as a woman and a new englander in
solidarity with the multiple student
groups who i've served throughout the
state of new hampshire at schools with
such scope as dartmouth college and the
university of new hampshire to urge you
just for hp 1477 which would protect the
lives of more than a million of your
constituents both born and pre-born
in a life or death setting the sign of
life that true medical professionals
look for is a heartbeat whether on the
battlefield or in the emergency room
that standard applies and yet with such
undeniable assurance that they are in
fact alive preborn children in the womb
face death
our current model fails in that it
allows the same people who would profit
off of the death of an infant in the
womb to quote unquote counsel
a pregnant woman on whether she should
buy an abortion from them
in such a delicate moment this allows
for a predatory abortion industry to
disregard her needs in favor of its own
financial gains
this is a conflict of interest serving a
billion dollar corporate entity and
abandons women in a moment of need
a majority of women who have had
abortions in the united states have said
that they felt coerced into getting an
abortion including by the abortion
industry which makes it imperative that
she would not be subjected to counseling
quote unquote
over a life or death matter in a
high-stakes sales environment
the majority of millennials in gen z the
target demographic of the abortion
industry who now make up roughly
one-third of the electorate reject
abortion violence
recent polling finds that three out of
four millennials in gen z support limits
on abortion while over half
support no abortion at all when a
heartbeat can be detected or only in
rare circumstances such as rape incest
or to save the life of the mother
in just over two short months since the
bill was introduced students for life
has collected more than a thousand
petitions in support of this bill i hold
one box of them we have
two more
um
in support of this bill with thousands
more that were mailed out and that are
still being processed at our
headquarters
every day and these boxes are full to
the brim
as members of gen z myself and the
students whom i serve stand for life
which is why i urge you today to support
hb 1477.
women deserve better than the violence
of abortion they deserve compassionate
solutions 15 seconds that do not cost
the lives of their children
as a society new hampshire can and must
do better thank you thank you ms
seeing none thank you again for your
testimony
hello thank you for letting me speak
today
my name is dr charlotte hastings and i'm
a resident physician in obstetrics and
gynecology
speaking in my capacity as a medical
doctor and as a reproductive health
specialist
i also speak today as someone who grew
up just across the border in vermont and
who went to high school in new hampshire
i have not just come here to train i was
raised here and i opposed house bill
1477.
three years ago i was training to become
an ob gyn in texas
working there i was faced with severe
restrictions on how to practice medicine
including an inability to provide
abortions to people who needed them
i left texas and returned to new
hampshire to train and practice because
of those restrictions
in texas part of my job was to
facilitate a support group for girls who
were under the age of 14 who were
pregnant
to be clear there were enough girls
under the age of 14
who were forced to carry a pregnancy to
term that they could fill in an entire
support group at one hospital there were
enough girls because of the abortion
restrictions that were in place in texas
i will never forget caring for the 13
year old girl
whose child was crying in the bassinet
next to her as she cried to her own
mother i oppose house bill 1477
because i do not want new hampshire to
become texas
i want us to protect our girls i want us
to help provide children and adolescents
with lives that they choose rather than
restrict their reproductive choices with
laws that we create
at six weeks of pregnancy many if not
most pregnant patients do not yet know
that they are pregnant
passing house bill 1477 would
effectively prevent access to abortion
for those patients
it's not difficult to imagine a 13 year
old girl in new hampshire
not knowing that she was pregnant until
seven weeks
this law would prevent her access to
abortion
all people deserve access to essential
health care and abortion is health care
thank you so much
thank you for your testimony any
questions for the doctor
xenon thank you
hi i'm roy dennehy and
i'm a life director for the new
hampshire
knights of columbus and i live in
windham new hampshire
[Music]
anti-life
pro-death supporters
constantly use the
following non-threatening phrases when
promoting
and supporting the evil of abortion
such as reproduction rights
restricting
reproduction freedom women's privacy
family planning and body of my choice
when would
who would object to these feel good
phrases
my response is when every abortion
procedure is performed on a pregnant
woman
a human life is killed
yes it's a pre-born baby girl or a boy
so intentionally and brutally killed
in its mother's womb
today the womb has become the most
dangerous place in america
because over one million deaths occur
in the womb each year here in the united
states
i am a committed christian along with
the vast majority of conservative
republicans in our state
we honor and adhere to the ten
commandments that god has given us to
follow
in god's fifth commandment states you
shall not kill whoever kills shall be
liable to judgment
god said to us in psalm 22 in the bible
before i formed you in the womb i knew
you
and before you were born
i consecrated you
thank god the majority of the house of
new hampshire voters in 2020 in 2020
elected a pro-life legislatures in both
the house and the senate
which resulted in the passage into law
of the fetal life protection act this
law legally protects the life of the
pre-born baby girls and boys from the
evil of abortion from the 24th week and
after conception to their natural birth
date
literally thousands of babies have been
saved
because of this historic lore in new
hampshire
planned parenthood the
quality health care
center
lovely health health center in new
hampshire
our abortion our abortion providers with
many quote killing clinics end of quote
they are one of the largest camp
campaign contributors to the democrat
party
and they are losing millions of dollars
in revenues
due to the passage of the fetal life
protection act
therefore from their perspective
the law must be
at a minimum gutted or ideally repealed
in the new hampshire house and senate
during this legislative session
to make matters worse even from a
financial standpoint
these abortion providers also 15 seconds
okay mr dennehy could hear you wrap up
okay
so therefore i strongly urge you to vote
for bill number 1477 thank you thank you
mr denny any questions from mr dennehy
seeing none thank you again
good morning again chair gordon and
members of the committee thank you so
much for hearing my testimony
my name again is laura godfrey and i'm
17 years old from portsmouth new
hampshire and i come before you today in
opposition to hb 1477 prohibiting
abortion after detection of a fetal
heartbeat
now this bill is modeled after texas's
sb 8 which is a similar ban that
restricts abortion after six weeks
but i want to point out that within 24
hours of the texas texas abortion bill
taking effect news outlets reported the
first death a new analysis from dr david
eisenberg who is a board certified
obstetrician gynecologist estimates that
with the new law in effect in texas the
state could see increases in maternal
mortality of up to 15 percent overall
and is based on previous research that
has established a clear link between
abortion restrictions and maternal
mortality
in a study published last march states
that restricted abortion had a maternal
death rate that was nearly double those
that had passed laws protecting access
to abortion
banning abortion like texas in new
hampshire is only guaranteed to hurt new
hampshire women
but on the note of mortality a counter
argument that might arise is the
included exception within the bill text
that an abortion is allowed in the case
a pregnant person will die or suffer the
impairment of a major bodily function
but there are three flaws with this
firstly this language is vague and not
inclusive of a variety of other
emergencies it ignores fetal
abnormalities or cases of rape or incest
and the vagueness of the language in
this bill will only hurt pregnant people
and doctors will struggle to find the
balance between the law and their
patient
secondly doctors may be reluctant to
intervene even in situations that
clearly qualify as emergencies how long
do doctors wait until they confirm that
the emergency will kill the mother
before performing the abortion
many pregnancy issues like eclampsia or
plan placenta accreta aren't always
killers but there is still a high risk
for organ loss or death
where is the line drawn
and thirdly the extreme nature of this
bill could also cause many abortion
clinics to close their doors which would
further reduce access to care for state
residents
this bill would make access to health
care all the more urgent and necessary
but its immediate after effects throw
doctors into doubt and close the doors
for abortion facilities
hb 1477 ignores the individual
circumstance through which pregnant
people want to get abortions
if you pass this bill you could force an
assault victim to carry her abuser's
pregnancy to turn
and some do not even have the means to
travel out of state to obtain legal
abortions
women will and have resorted to using
coat hangers downing down pills or
hurting themselves to get rid of a
pregnancy they cannot support
this committee has to understand 15
seconds matter the ban abortion is still
going to happen but it is up to you to
decide whether or not those abortions
will be safe okay could you finish i
urge you to itl this bill thank you
thank you for your testimony today are
seeing that again thank you
hi there my name is louise spencer from
concord new hampshire
and i i think in a
debate as important as one surrounding
reproductive freedom and control of
one's body
it's really important to have
the facts at hand and
study after study has shown that
women
over both short term periods such as
five years
or long term periods
generally
not in every instance for sure and we've
heard
testimony about
women who do regret their abortions
but that the majority of women
describe the primary emotion as relief
that they were able to access
abortion care and that they were able to
have that kind of control over their
body
and their life
so i just think it's really essential
that
as we're considering these questions
that we look at
the data
as it stands
there's also very good data
on generational breakdowns about
support for reproductive freedom
and
i think there's some important
statistics there too that we can send
along so thank you very much
thank you for your testimony
any questions for mr spencer
seeing them again thank you
dr young
thank you again
i will forego
my introduction since i already gave
that to you
i want to make clear that
intravaginal ultrasound is so sensitive
today we're picking up fetal hearts
five to six weeks following the first
day
of a woman's last menstrual period or
three to four weeks gestation a time
when most women
do not know
that they're pregnant
so if this bill passes
it becomes a statute it will essentially
i'm just old enough to have experienced
the sweeping change we saw
when abortion became
legal
as a third year medical student at saint
paul ramsey county hospital
i admitted a young woman
with vaginal bleeding
hypotension fever and chills
she admitted
that she had had a botched abortion
in the back galley
of saint paul
city
we gave her iv fluids we gave her the
best antibiotics that were available at
the time
then we took her to the operating room
and removed a perforated uterus it was
filled with pus
i can still smell the stench
i asked her why she wasn't using birth
control
she said she couldn't use birth control
because she was catholic
i asked her why she didn't tell her
parents
about her pregnancy
she said she couldn't tell them
her father was responsible for her
pregnancy
and she said her mom would have died if
she had learned that her daughter was
pregnant
unfortunately she did die
this was an honor student
this was a star of her high school
nine
of what was a classic
septic abortion so common
i've testified before this committee
many times
i was always concerned that i might
break down
telling it
i can still see this young woman 15
seconds
we cannot
go back
others should not be making decisions
for women especially when it comes to
pregnancy
please
oppose this bill
thank you
any questions for dr young
see none thank you for your testimony
good morning i'm sarah smith from
pembroke new hampshire
um
and i
i just i think there have been some
wonderful testimony i oppose this bill
uh for
one you can see there is no exception
for rape in this bill
and uh at
at six weeks that's not enough time to
really get ready for this at
this event
um i'll give you another real life
example from my own life
one time i became pregnant and i did not
realize i was pregnant until
18 weeks
this is real folks this is not just what
somebody is saying as testimony that
they've heard this is real people people
do not realize that they're pregnant
right away
it is possible to go a long time and not
know it
so there you have
no exception for rape a rape victim
doesn't realize she's pregnant until
many many months many many weeks later
this is about
choice
women having a choice if they choose to
carry a pregnancy then they don't need
to have an abortion if they do not
choose they have that right to choose
they have that private bodily autonomy
that we talk about so much
that is their right
and this this bill takes away that right
in the most egregious way
anybody have any questions
any
any questions for missman
saying none thank you for your
morning thank you for hearing me again
today
i don't want to repeat any testimony
specifically but i do want to just
highlight a couple of things from a
medical perspective
what several other
people have testified
i will concur that
six weeks of pregnancy is in fact
usually the very earliest that a woman
will know that she's pregnant um because
of the way that we calculate
gestational age based on a woman's last
menstrual period
because of the amazing technology that
we have now with ultrasounds we are
able to detect the very earliest
electrical impulses of
an embryo's cardiac activity at that
time sometimes around around that time
of six weeks
but it's not a proxy for
viability of an embryo
about one in four pregnancies
actually ended miscarriage in the first
trimester because
most of the development of organs are
happening and there can be chromosomal
abnormalities early early in pregnancy
many women don't know that they're
pregnant
because they don't have regular
menstrual periods
or maybe they have other reasons that
could prevent them from getting to
a doctor's office most of the patients
that i see
present for their first prenatal
appointment or their first
indication of pregnancy later than six
weeks
here
in the united states we don't have the
best sexual health education and i also
would just like to highlight that
adolescents may not have the resources
available to them
to have access to contraception
to know that they're pregnant
or to be able to prevent pregnancy and
even those who
are trying to prevent pregnancy they
still have barriers a lot of
patients are scaled scared to tell their
parents or their partners that they are
pregnant and there are many barriers to
abortion care
because of the gestational age this bill
effectively would
eliminate abortion for all granite
staters
abortion is a safe common and essential
component of health care i'm too young
to have experienced the experiences that
dr young is mentioning and i don't want
to ever see them
we have shown
through data that abortion is
safe it is an essential component of
health care and it is something that
i need to be able to counsel my patients
on as an option
it is not the answer for everyone but it
should be a medically safe
option for women in our state i oppose
this bill thank you for hearing my
testimony
any questions for the doctor
seeing none again thank you for your
testimony
hello again my name is josie pinto a
constituent of dover testifying in
opposition to hp 1477.
as i mentioned previously i run an
organization that aids people in
accessing abortion services i have
direct experience working at a
reproductive health center and every day
i help patients figure out how they can
access abortion
an abortion ban at the point of fetal
heartbeat would be absolutely
detrimental to the health and well-being
of granite staters and would force the
majority of people seeking abortions to
have to go out of state for that care
i have watched as fellow abortion funds
in texas help coordinate care for
patients experiencing a six-week ban and
it has led to absolute logistical
nightmares
the surrounding states near texas can't
keep up with the demand often booking
weeks out
many people find themselves having to
get plane tickets to get care
we know we've even had patients come up
to new hampshire from texas
and we're among the furthest possible
states
that's just the consequences of one
state enacting a six-week ban
what's to come if more states enact
similar bans as well
the fact is people are not going to stop
getting abortions but laws like this put
a massive strain on patients and
organizations like the one i run
they add a massive cost burden to an
already expensive situation
cause patients to have to take
significant times off of work get hotels
and so on
there would be absolutely no way to meet
the full needs of patients if this law
were to pass which is exactly the point
of legislation like this
at six weeks many people do not know
they are pregnant yet
let alone able to get an abortion
appointment by that time
as others have said it bears mentioning
that pregnancy is calculated from the
last date of your menstrual period
meaning that a six weeks pregnant is
very close to someone's missed period
and could be
understood as a two-week ban
it's impossible to expect people to get
an appointment made that quickly and as
such this bill would essentially ban
nearly all abortions
as it stands this law would be blatantly
unconstitutional
at a time when our rights hang in the
balance at the federal level we need to
be doing everything we can to ensure
abortion remains accessible not harder
to access
the detrimental impact on public health
economic well-being and patient safety
cannot be understated here
i urge you all to vote inexpedient to
legislate on this bill thank you
any questions
thank you any questions for
ms pinto
seeing none thank you thank you for your
testimony today is there anyone who
hasn't testified who would like to
seeing none we will close the hearing on
house bill
and that includes our concludes our
docket for the morning and the committee
the primary sponsor of this bill is
representative kelsey
and we will call upon her to introduce
the bill and provide her testimony
again for those who weren't here this
morning what we will do is give each of
the sponsors of the bill who testify
five minutes to
explain their bill
and then
with regard to testimony today each
person will be limited to three minutes
of testimony
thank you
good afternoon mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is nikki kelsey i represent bedford
hillsborough district 7.
i come to you today to bring you house
bill 1625 which i like to call the
sidewalk free speech act
freedom of speech is protected not only
by the u.s constitution but by the new
hampshire bill of rights
our state constitution is even more
adamant than our federal first amendment
part one article 22
says that free speech should be
inviolably preserved yet free speech
faces growing threats at both the
federal and state levels from those who
would suppress their opponent's speech
because they fear losing an open contest
of ideas
these threats should be reminders of why
the freedom of speech is protected in
our constitution
supreme court justice william o douglas
once said that freedom of speech may
indeed best serve its high purpose when
it induces a condition of unrest or even
stirs people to anger speech is often
provocative and challenging that is why
freedom of speech is protected against
censorship or punishment
abortion is one issue where there is
unrest on both sides of the debate
both new hampshire's buffer zone law
represents an attempt to stifle the
contentious debate surrounding abortion
rather than allowing freedom of speech
to serve its purpose
the buffer zone law allows abortion
clinics to demarcate a 25-foot zone
around clinics in which nobody may
counsel against or protest abortion
supporters of the buffer zone law might
claim that it functions to protect women
who are seeking an abortion from being
assaulted or harassed
but the truth is assault
criminal threatening and harassment are
all already illegal in new hampshire
the actual effect of the law is to
privilege pro-abortion speech and
marginalized speech critical of abortion
the bill that i am introducing would
repeal the buffer zone law yet it should
merit the votes of not only the pro-life
or even those who simply champion free
speech but all of those who value full
responsible government
that's because in 2014 massachusetts
buffer zone law was declared
unconstitutional by the u.s supreme
court
our buffer zone law is identical in all
relevant aspects to this
unconstitutional massachusetts law if
our buffer zone law is legally
challenged it will be repealed
and new hampshire will have wasted
taxpayers money defending a law that is
not only unjust but unconstitutional and
futile
for all these reasons the buffer zone
law should be repealed thank you so much
are there questions for representative
kelsey
very much mr chair thank you very much
representative kelsey you mentioned in
counseling potential patients in front
of the clinic is there
is there a first amendment right or some
other right to provide counseling
services um
without a license and without the
necessarily the counselees express
permission
thank you for your question i'm not
actually sure how to answer that i could
okay any other questions representative
kelsey
see none thank you for your testimony
thank you so much
representative stapleton
thank you mr chair members of the
committee
my name is walter stapleton
i'm a representative in the house here
for the third ward of claremont sullivan
i am testifying in support uh as a
co-sponsor of hp 1625 to repeal the
prohibition on entering and remaining on
a public sidewalk at or adjacent
to a reproductive health care facility
as if they are so-called
but i am also director of
upper valley pray for life a project of
the knights of columbus
claremont council 1820
we consider ourselves a pro-life council
in new hampshire's state council and for
the
2 million members
worldwide
in the knights of columbus
we
are not demonstrators
or interveners to access to those
facilities
our purpose there is to pray for the
unborn
the preborn
the mothers
we understand that
by being
harassing
difficult
annoying
we're not gaining anything we actually
would be setting back our purposes
for the protection of life in the womb
and for aid to
the mothers who are going in and out of
those places and to encourage
alternatives such as adoption
and referring referrals to the 12 other
pro-life abortion centers in new
hampshire
who provide free ultrasounds
aid to mothers counseling
and
a number of services to help people
through the difficult
time of
childbirth being alone
we also have remedial
centers we can refer to such as rachel's
place
for women who have had an abortion
and are plagued with the hurt and the
guilt
and the trauma
of that experience of having
destroyed
a human being
we are trained
by the
sidewalk for life incorporated people
which is a national organization
on how to behave
how to approach people in a friendly
manner
in a helpful manner
and we remind our members all the time
that
we are
prayerful respectful
and lawful on the sidewalk
so that we can help people
instead of
a sale
and that concludes my testimony asking
for support
of 1625 has thought to pass
thank you representative chase did you
have a question
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i i couldn't really
hear you and i was just wondering if you
could clarify
the um
did you say that the knights of columbus
provides ultrasound and prenatal care
and counseling for women
right the
some of the 12
free pro-life abortion clinics in the
state of new hampshire
do provide free ultrasound as a matter
of fact
our council 1820 in claremont raised
funds and helped install two ultrasounds
one in claremont and one in west lebanon
for the day spring pregnancy center
and we're talking about tens of
thousands of dollars
and we know that uh
85 to 95 percent of the women who see
that ultrasound sonogram image often
adopt or or opt to keep the child
other questions for representative
stapleton
cnn thank you for your testimony today
thank you mr chair
i see that there are a couple of other
reps in the room who are co-sponsors but
i don't have cards from them do they
want to testify at all
there is another representative wish to
phillips thank you representative mary
hacken phillips of grafton county
district 12 representing hanover lime i
rise in opposition to hb 1625 for four
reasons
first the bill suffers from a faulty
premise that the first amendment of
freedom of speech is absolute
the supreme court of the united states
has repeatedly held that the free
freedom of speech is limited and
qualifiable for example
imminent threats hate speech and
fighting words are not protected
a basic tenet of american political
thought has established that one
citizen's right to exercise a
constitutionally protected protected
activity ends at another citizen's right
to be free from an unlawful prohibition
of a constitutionally protected activity
thus once limited free speech ends at
another's fundamental right to access
health care
second the bill suffers from a misguided
application of precedent in 2014 a
plurality of scotus held in the mccullen
versus coakley case that a massachusetts
law mandating a 35-foot buffer zone
around a clinic that provided abortions
was presumptively unconstitutional
unless
a state more narrowly tailored its law
to target clinic obstructions
and a basic public right-of-way within
the demarcation of the buffer zone
the supreme court held that the public
discourse on a public right-of-way is
protected
and that laws making it illegal to
attempt to intimidate injure or
interfere with anyone coming or going
from an abortion clinic within the zone
are constitutional
but the authors of the bill do not
understand this nuance
instead they select a part of the legal
precedent that is politically expedient
and you can see the specific failure of
analysis present in section roman
numeral four of the bill which is
duplicative of existing legal rights
section roman numeral five and six of
the bill also inappropriately assert
that all of the rsas
codifying the access to reproductive
health care facilities is likely to be
struck down by the coakley precedent
which is plain wrong
the supreme court has said that the
state of massachusetts closed a
substantial portion of a traditional
public forum
to all speakers a content neutral act
but the court would allow a more
narrowly tailored law
that serves a significant government
interest rrsas do serve a critical
public service
and purpose the right to access
healthcare
third the mechanics of the severability
clause and skoda's precedent maintain
that if any part of the existing law
fails to be valid under a court order
then the rest of the law remains valid
to the extent it makes sense the effect
of the 2014 scope is precedent therefore
means that our our states would remain
largely intact
fourth and finally total repeal of this
rsa section would be a mistake repeal
would create an undue burden on a
pregnant person's right to access
reproductive health care facilities and
it would remove the significant
remaining portions of the law that the
supreme court has upheld worse it would
create an atmosphere of free range
imminent threats intimidation of those
seeking abortion and no enforcement
against those who are violent or
exercising unprotected speech within
that zone
practically speaking it makes our health
care providers and law enforcement
officers jobs much more difficult
please support their efforts thus i urge
you
to itl
hp1625 thank you
thank you
exactly three minutes
are there questions
yes represent mclean
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um i i was trying to
catch everything you're saying but you
were going really quick i think to get
in inside that three-minute margin but
could you tell me
what the differences are between the
massachusetts law and our law
that you think
would insulate
our law
versus you know their law based on the
mccullen versus coakley decision thank
you representative that is an excellent
question one which is very difficult to
articulate within the three-minute time
period um and which extended legal
analysis would um
you know it's difficult to provide you
with that here but essentially i can
tell you that the massachusetts law was
content neutral it outlawed all public
discourse in a public walkway
our rsa is more specifically toned
to providing a buffer zone and then
prohibiting certain people from entering
it um but you'll notice in those
exceptions that any person using the
public right-of-way is welcome to go
through that space especially if they're
just you know passing through
the point of the scotus legal analysis
that would be applicable to the
exceptions would just be simply to
affect effectively
i think it's rsa 132 colin
38 subsection d
from roman numeral 1 6 sub section d
it's a specific part of the law that
talks about that public walkway and
whether or not people can move through
that space of course we know that scotus
has said anyone can use public discourse
in the public walkway
and our our law is nearly
narrowly tailored to specifically allow
people to use that space you would just
simply have to remove the second half of
the clause of this
uh sentence in order to make it
more
you know in align with the scotus
precedent which means that the rest of
the rsa stands on its own
that small removal of a spot is severed
the small removal of that sentence is
severed from the entire rsa so the
remaining still makes sense remaining
laws still hold legal precedent and
protections for both protesters and
people seeking health care
um
at those facilities as well as those
providers and employees and law
enforcement personnel
so to strike the entire law does not
make sense okay
for attorney hawkins phillips
xenon thank you for your testimony today
chairman
and committee members
respectfully yeah you need to speak into
the mic better how's that
good
chairman and committee members
respectfully
my name is noelle olson i'm a resident
of hopkinton
thank you for the opportunity to share
testimony regarding house bill 1625
please support this bill
accordingly
women who are considering an abortion
deserve the opportunity to receive
information that may help them to
continue with their pregnancies
briefly
i'll share a snapshot of experiences
that help in understanding the distress
of a crisis pregnancy
and the import of an exchange of
information surrounding choices
i'm a post-abortive woman
i experienced a saline abortion in new
york city in july of 1970.
i was 15 years old accompanied by my
mother who is 37.
although strongly opposed to abortion
the adults in my life succumb to outside
pressure framed from around my youth
continued education and loss of future
opportunities coercion and fear put me
on the abortion train
my family did not have ready access to
information about alternatives to
abortion
would i have had the courage to choose
life if i had encountered someone
silently praying on the sidewalk or
better yet
offering ready resources to support me
in crisis
now
52 years later my brain continues to
black out significant chunks of memory
from that week in new york city
it's a human survival response to trauma
i now understand that only a shadow of a
once vibrant girl emerged from that
typical patterns of behavior for many
post-abortive women include
substance abuse broken or abusive
relationships and poor decision-making
results of injury to the prefrontal
cortex through experienced trauma
some of my post-abortive experiences
were consistent with this pattern over
many decades in 1970
no one met me on the sidewalk to offer
an alternative to abortion
without the support of informational
intervention my mother was not equipped
to help me to carry a crisis pregnancy
to term
many women are abort out of desperation
and ignorance of community support
systems in place
and ready to help
please
protect our first amendment right to
speech in this case
effective discourse that supports women
in crisis with potential for saving a
life thank you
are there questions
seeing them thank you for your testimony
today
thank you mr sheridan members of the
committee
my name is maria perez i'm a state
representative from district 23 mail for
new hampshire and i'm here to testify in
a position as a still
i'm someone
who
was a victim of
incest from the age of five years old
it's hard to hear people saying freedom
of speech
when i didn't have that when i was a
little girl 5 years old
i went through that trauma until i was
15 years old
i moved here
and i was a victim of domestic violence
i'm sick and tired of people telling me
what what is right and what is wrong for
victims like myself
i had enough
staying quiet because
for my family it was better to stay
quiet because
they don't want to be appointed by the
society because
my own father did that to me
my father was a well-known person
where i came from
and my mom was so afraid that people
gonna judge us because people are gonna
start talking about my family because
i was gonna tell people that i was
abused by my own dad
on second time people told me that is
okay
i'm sick and tired of people say that we
have to carry babies
even though
that can be that that means caring baby
from my own father
i was abused again
when i was nine years old for another
other members of the family
it's not easy for me to speak up here
it's not it's not easy for me to be in
front of you guys
but i just want to let you know
that is someone who's been going through
so much
i went back to school because i want to
be better
i had the choice to use drugs
i had the choice to be a better a bad
person
but i choose to be a good person i
choose to learn the language
yes i may not speak
but i try to do the best i can
i work really hard
to build a good family to be
big build a good foundation for both of
my kids
both of my kids graduated from college
do you imagine if i was pregnant for my
own dad
in an early age
what happened to the future of my two
kids do you imagine me looking on my
kids and say well
this is your brother
representative perez could you wrap up
your testimony please for that reason
i'm opposing this bill and i ask every
single member of this committee
to please please i tell this deal
big that's not myself we need respect
any questions for the representative
good afternoon my name is kathleen
yanian and i have been a sidewalk
advocate for over three years at the
planned parenthood facility in
manchester
i support house bill 1625
as a wife mother grandmother and
registered nurse for over 34 years
my hope as a sidewalk advocate is to
help women by providing good and
alternative information
which includes a list of community
resources
and alternative information
excuse me both public and private such
as pregnancy help centers
information on fetal development
post-abortive health groups and most
importantly a listening ear
to those conflicted
at no time have i witnessed any
counseling
prayer is said by those gathered for
both the women walking in
and staff working at the facility
at no time have i witnessed violence at
planned parenthood in manchester
the manchester police details were ended
almost two years ago and replaced with a
security person
which to my understanding is only on
wednesday's surgical abortion day
their role as i have witnessed is to
walk clients into the building within
the fenced parking lot
and open the door
some sit in their cars while others
remain inside the facility
a remarkable testimony to the passing of
house bill 1625
thank you for your time an opportunity
to speak with you
and may god bless the great state of new
hampshire and may god bless america
thank you ms yanian any questions
see none thanks again
good afternoon members of the committee
again my name is kayla montgomery and i
represent planned parenthood and we
oppose house bill 1625
so first just as some quick background
on this bill this body passed to senate
bill 319 and was signed into law back in
2014.
this legislation was to address public
safety concerns
by allowing a non-mandatory patient
safety zone of up to 25 feet surrounding
entrances to reproductive health
facilities
this flexible
this flexibility allows for communities
to tailor a zone in accordance to local
factors and local public safety needs
so i want to just explain a little bit
about why patients and providers need
the flexibility to use the patient
safety zones
so reproductive health centers in new
hampshire have always felt the impact of
protest activities however following
national trends over the past few years
the volume and the frequency of these
protests have increased particularly
since the pandemic began
some of the types of the harassing
tactics that our local health center
deals with
are the obstruction of the driveway
entrance so protesters will gather in
front of the driveway and they'll often
block it with a physical object at the
entrance which creates a barrier for
patients who are trying to enter the
health center forcing patients to
unnecessarily wait as the driveway gets
cleared
protesters also invade the privacy of
those who do not wish to engage in
dialogue with them while entering or
exiting the building
there is blocking of on-street parking
spaces verbal assaults
photographing of patients and providers
this is all a violation of patient
privacy but it is also a major public
safety issue
in fact
the unnecessarily congested driveway has
caused patients to become confused and
distracted and has actually led to some
minor car accidents so to try to
mitigate the harm of this public safety
situation planned parenthood has had to
install a new fence to help patients
navigate this issue
and while the fence is better for
patient safety it has completely changed
the privacy around the parking lot and
it now allows protesters to have full
visibility into the parking lot
planned parenthood is forced to change
uh it's forced to trade patient privacy
for public safety when in fact everyone
deserves to have both and currently yes
planned parenthood uses on
on-site security controlling twenty-five
thousand dollars per year and calls the
police are certainly much more frequent
so establishing a patient safety zone is
just one tool in the toolkit for health
centers and local authorities to use
while working together to protect public
safety and privacy of patients and
providers
while also balancing first amendment
rights so it's not necessarily the first
or the only tool that health centers and
communities have the flexibility to use
the zone if needed
in conclusion
thank you in conclusion no one should
face violence harassment or threats when
accessing safe legal care everyone the
governor to legislators to patients
deserve to feel safe
uh when they're accessing the care they
need
planned parenthood certainly recognizes
first amendment uh peaceful free speech
but this law does not violate it just
bad other questions from ms montgomery
ms chase
representative thank you thank you mr
chair and thank you mr montgomery for
taking my question could you just um
enlighten me about what the future would
hold if this bill were to go into effect
certainly thank you for the question um
planned parenthood is certainly
thinking a lot about what a post-role
world looks like i'm sure everyone in
this committee understands
that a row could be overturned as soon
as june
which would mean that many states
probably up to 26 states would move to
ban or deeply restrict access
immediately
we know that
when that happens
there will be many more patients coming
to new hampshire coming to northern new
england coming to states where abortion
is still legal we also know that with
that will come more protesters because
when abortion is illegal in their state
they will go to places where abortion is
legal so we do expect many more
protesters
after row falls when row falls if roe
falls
and we know that these tactics are
getting
much bolder i'm sure everyone also
recently saw that planned parenthood was
destroyed in an arson fire just a few
representative otter thank you mr
chairman thank you for taking the
question you had mentioned the driveway
being blocked is there a police report
that you could provide to us
i don't have something i can provide you
right now but yes there's lots of police
reports that are filed we work
with the manchester police specifically
the community policing division
we do calls with them we talk with them
so there's quite a few
over the years there's quite a few filed
representative mclean
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so um
you you gave some testimony as to some
of the obstacles you faced you talked
about you know creating a barrier for
the patients photographing and insulting
people
so this law in new hampshire has been in
effect for seven years
why have you chosen not to exercise this
law and take advantage of its provisions
in the last seven years if your
your patients are so threatened sure
thank you for the question like i
mentioned in my testimony we do feel
it's an important tool in the toolkit
not necessarily the first not
necessarily the only we do work on
incremental steps in order to create
public safety like i mentioned we
work with the manchester mayor i believe
she submitted testimony today we work
the community policing division
um
some things have taken a little bit
longer than we had hoped certainly these
things do take time to do them right we
were the manchester health center went
over went through renovations changing
the footprint particularly the parking
lot and those just wrapped up last year
so that was a little bit of a delay but
you know also i think it's really
important to note that planned
parenthood is not the only
the only enforcement here that is a
shared enforcement with planned
parenthood and with the new hampshire
ag's office
and so i i think if there feels like
there needs to be a little bit more
alignment that would be a great question
for the ag's office and we'd be happy to
have that conversation
and if i may um you asked a question of
the representative from grafton earlier
about the massachusetts law and she did
an excellent job of explaining the
differences between the massachusetts
law
and i just want to add two points to it
if that's okay with you um
the massachusetts law which was struck
down by this u.s supreme court it was a
non-flexible law and it was 35 feet and
it was for every reproductive health
center regardless of whether they wanted
it or not regardless of whether it
worked in their community the difference
is that this law it is uh not mandatory
it's only if reproductive health centers
want it and it is up to 25 feet so one
community might want five feet one might
want
feet but it's the flexibility that is
one of the key differences between the
man the massachusetts law which was
struck down in new hampshire
thank you my my rational next election
is but having confirmed it wasn't um
the new hampshire law
um
rewritten well written and then
substantially revised
after the mccullen versus coakley case
made it to the supreme court
with an eye towards avoiding the
problems that
led to that
law eventually being overturned
or at least
i'm not sure of the exact timing on the
massachusetts law but i can tell you on
the new hampshire law if i understand
your question correctly the new
hampshire law the actual
constitutionality of the new hampshire
law has never been tested because it has
never been enforced and so
when this law passed back in 2014
protester the protesters asked for
specifically for this law to be
overturned the
judge dismissed the case for lack of
standing and that was back in
i'm sure that many people on this
committee are familiar with that case it
was the mary rose ready versus attorney
joe foster law and then that was
reaffirmed by the
first district court of appeals back in
and when that decision came out in 2016
the judge also made it clear of some of
the differences between the new
hampshire law and the massachusetts law
because it was very timely but i'm not
sure which came first
seeing none thank you for your testimony
today
hi good afternoon
chairman committee members
respectfully
my name is susan clifton
i'm a retired registered nurse i am here
to support bill 1625
to repeal the buffer zone legislation
i've been offering help on the sidewalk
for many years in manchester in front of
planned parenthood i witness the
desperation
and the devastation
of women going in and coming out
i've also been witness
to the women who have been thrown a
lifeline
and opted to choose life for their
just so you know we are peaceful
we don't judge
we don't block anyone
and we don't harass
we simply offer
help
hope
and options
i recall a couple of years ago
for example we met a young woman and
there was a language barrier
she did not speak a word of english
somehow though she understood
and took up the offer of help all free
she was literally given a new family
who took her in
and she now has a little girl who's a
year and a half old and both of them are
other women have come back
to thank us just for being there
for the support or even
for the baby showers we might have
thrown them
and simply they are just grateful
for the presence of others who help them
to choose life
women deserve good information
on their way in we offer the resources
of the local pregnancy center
just a few hundred feet from the clinic
down the street
if they're coming out of the clinic
we are sometimes able to refer them to
rachel's vineyard an international
post-abortion
healing program for women and men
for which i am a volunteer
either way whether going in
or coming out our approach
is always one of love and compassion
i ask that you simply work to protect
our right to free speech on the sidewalk
as this is the american way
thank you kindly for your time and
please support house bill 1625
thank you are there questions
representative notter
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question i've been on that
sidewalk before and and i've seen um
firsthand that it's peaceful
um but i
haven't been there in a while um
my question to you is have you yourself
ever been harassed or or um
called terrible names because that's
what i experienced when i was there from
others yes i mean it's kind of a regular
thing that
people will shout things or
you know
use a certain gesture possibly but um
we always just
we just try to always respond in love
that's all
it's it's to be expected i guess
other questions yes representative kenny
thank you and uh thank you for taking my
question so i hear you that you respond
in love and and i'm not questioning
anyone's intention who comes here uh who
has good intentions but do you believe
that every single after other
testimonies we've heard every single
person who engages in in a similar
activity does have good intentions they
they are being respectful they are being
loving because because i well yes
well
i mean i'm just one individual i can't
control what anybody else does on the
sidewalk anybody that shows up it's a
you know we live in a free country so i
can't just automatically assume to know
what anybody is going to say
um
but
you have something else
yeah you would like to follow up and i
mean this with due respect but in a free
country don't people deserve to go to a
medical
procedure without unsolicited advice
especially because i know you're just
you know
not the best intentions not love not
everything you said
uh
like we don't we don't we don't uh stop
anybody certainly or we just offer help
when we're there and we don't try to
interfere we just offer simply offer
help that's all we're just there we
don't harass we don't
push anyone
we respect everyone's boundaries
i don't know what else to say but
thank you for taking my questions yeah
you're welcome
thank you thank you for your testimony
today
it's working okay
good afternoon representatives i'm brian
brian harlow from concord and i'm
speaking against house bill 1625.
women and everyone deserve to enter a
healthcare facility free from
intimidation and shame
i've heard and read a lot of
condemnation and derision
in regards to the women walking into
facilities
rest assured these women many of them
courageous survivors of domestic and
sexual violence
are well aware of what they're
undertaking in choosing
i've worn the rainbow vest before and
it's not something that's in my comfort
zone but
i felt it was something i should do
as a catholic raised man in this society
i've come up believing that i'm right no
matter what when it comes to this issue
while i'm not here to debate pro-choice
versus pro-life in regards to hb 1625
i'm here to tell you i've worked with
many victims of sexual violence in the
issue most paramount to their recovery
is to show them safety community and
body autonomy is possible again
1625 will be a direct assault on women's
right to feel safe in their life choices
without walking through
a phalanx of those who presume to know
better than her
lastly i have a strong gift in an
independent little girl
no legislators need insult her
intelligence
along the way by the presumption that
she didn't weigh all sides of an issue
trying to enter the healthcare facility
women are well aware of what's going on
i assure you thank you for your time
any questions from mr harlow
hello my name is beth gaby
i live here in concord
and i am a homebirth midwife by trade
i'm here to vote yes for this bill
um
my
my voice today is for 40 days for life i
am the leader of 40 days for life which
is a prayer and fasting campaign
to pray for the end of abortion
this happens in concord during lent
there's a 40 day
24 7 prayer vigil on the sidewalk in
front of the concord equality health
center
and
i never thought i would be on the
sidewalk
and it's a very challenging experience
so what i do is i go there
and i
pray that's all i do
it's just me myself and i i don't
generally have a sign if i have a sign
it's our lady of guadalupe the mother of
jesus kind of on me
and so i've observed a lot over six
years
and during this time that the buffer
zone has been in in place but it's never
been enforced
and in this um so what i observe from
the street when you have
pro-life people
and you have
pro-choice people and we all know it's a
very
conflict dialogue
um
is that it's reminded me of playground
i'm like man this is like this can be
really juvenile often it's just really
you know just nothing just very people
work well together very respectful and
then you get these
spouts of like conflict and so it just
it can bring out the worst in people can
bring out the best and all of this is
happening without any buffer zone
happening at all so um the police have
been called a few times there have been
various things and then also we've had
very respectful dialogues and i have a
very good working relationship with
dahlia who's the director of the
equality health center and
so the way i feel about the reason i
feel like everybody should vote yes on
this bill regardless of your pro-choice
or pro-life convictions
is because
it is
free speech working
and it's kind of messy sometimes but
it's working
the current law has a buffer zone
involved and i'm on the street it has
not enforced and it hasn't needed to be
enforced because people have used and
again sometimes it's messy but we've
been able to kind of make it through
so in my mind
when the buffer zone law went into
effect seven minutes ago
um that's three minutes sorry seven
years
that's three minutes i'm sorry
that's three minutes you're three
minutes later oh okay if you could just
finish up please oh just just saying
that um to keep the law straight and
narrow keep freedom of speech and then
um any kind of buffer zone really brings
the law into kind of like a playground
mentality and so i say repeat you know
repeal do this freedom act bill it's
just going to be freedom of speech thank
you
thank you ms gaby
and other questions from miss gaby
cnn thank you for your testimony
paul
galasso
hi good afternoon
uh thank you
for taking the time out to
give me the opportunity to speak on
behalf
i am one of the sidewalk advocates i've
been doing this at penacook for six
years now
prior to that when i lived in texas i
did it for about 10 years
when i hear the word protest i cringe a
little bit because we're not protesters
this is different than
20 30 years ago when you saw people with
horrible signs
very aggressively
attacking women entering planned
parenthood facilities
that's not what we're about
to try to give you a picture of what the
sidewalk looks like
on wednesdays which is the only day that
we we're there because we don't have
enough volunteers
there's about
four or five
people in the morning
standing
outside of the planned parenthood away
from the driveway
offering help with signs that say we can
help you
please come talk to me
same thing happens in the afternoon we
have another group that comes in
or all senior citizens
during the summer occasionally we have
some high school kids come over and help
us
but our mission isn't to insult
intimidate humiliate or threaten
what we do is when a woman is
approaching the planned parenthood
facility
we show the sign and we say
if you want us to help you
we can
you do have a choice
there's another
alternative if you can't keep your baby
we can help you adopt it
please come and talk to us
that's the dynamic that goes on in front
of planned parenthood
we're not there
in a way that some may think
and that in the way that some have said
here
so i'd ask that you would please support
bill 1625
to enable us to continue to help women
we do have
successes we have women come over to us
as was talked about earlier
they change their minds they have their
babies
they come back we have baby showers
we can bring something that was very
threatening
and fearful to a woman
to a very positive end
and what we often say in closing is
rather than going to planned parenthood
and suffering the potential after
effects
be a hero
and have your baby
and we do all this in the name of jesus
christ
thank you mr glasso
seeing none thank you again for
testifying today
hi my name is francis hines
i'm from windham new hampshire i support
house bill
1625 which will return
we're having a hard time hearing you so
you got to speak right into the mic
i support house bill 1625 which will
return free speech to the public
sidewalks in front of abortion
facilities
when democrat senator maggie hassan then
governor
signed into law
an unconstitutional buffer zone law
almost eight years ago
i had no idea
that maggie was a leader
in what we all know now
as the cancel culture
what's cancel culture
it's not accepting the liberal
establishment liberal media and big tech
agenda
loss of freedoms
here's some examples if you post on
facebook now
if a face mask works then why don't they
work
facebook will cancel you there's no free
speech
when joe rogan discussed the efficacy
of covet mra
vaccines with dr malone who invented
them
and holds patents on the process
dr malone gets cancelled and the white
house demands that spotify cancel joe
ragan rogan
the freedom truckers want covert
mandates to end so gofundme cancels them
by taking their money
no free speech
have a religious or medical objection to
the covenant
vaccines
and remain unvaccinated
then your job will cancel you loss of
freedom
this is the cancel culture brought to
new hampshire with the buffer zone
if you exercise your right to free
speech on the public sidewalk
of new hampshire in front of an abortion
center and have the wrong
viewpoint
that is that the killing of an unborn
baby is wrong
then the buffalo zone law will cancel
you
you will be warned fined and arrested
knowing that planned parenthood can
activate the bus buffer zone anytime
they want
has a chilling effect on free speech i
know
because most wednesday mornings i pray
on the public sidewalks in front of
planned parenthood in manchester
i occasionally engage in conversations
with people walking by who stopped to
talk to me
the buffer zone law is a disgrace
to the first amendment freedoms of all
new hampshire residents
i support hb
to restore our freedom of speech on
public sidewalks thank you thank you
questions representative chase did you
thank you and thank you for taking my
question i'm a bit confused you're
saying that even with the law that it is
right now you're still able to be out
there and pray and help people if they
need it so
where are you where is your freedom of
speech being diminished because i know
that at any time
planned parenthood can activate this law
and it's it's oh it's being held over
our heads there's no necessity either
activate this law
and we'll deal with it in the courts
or repeal this law and restore our
freedoms
other questions
uh representative kenny yeah thank you
for taking my question so
you know i i hear you that
you have good intentions being out there
but as been pointed out people do not
agree on this issue and you say you're
on those sidewalks but then right here
in your testimony you said do the right
thing do not kill your baby is that the
advice that people are getting as they
i don't talk to very many people but i
think paul glasso
told exactly what happens at manchester
planned parenthood i'm not aware what
happens at other facilities because i
only go to manchester planned parenthood
and we have signs that say
please talk to us we'll help you some
representative horrigan thank you very
much mr chair and
actually
you segued into vaccines and there have
been cases where people try to interfere
with uh
vaccine clinics so do you
support those like the gentleman who was
arrested outside the courier museum and
manchester in october for harassing
people a vaccine clinic so do you
support that and i guess how would you
feel
would you feel the same way how would
you feel about a law some sort of law
preventing
you know
specifically protecting vaccine clinics
i i support freedom of choice
and if people want to get the vaccine
they should be able to if they don't
want to
they don't have to
thank you for your testimony
thank you for hearing my testimony again
today
i oppose this bill
house bill 1625
we all know that abortion is a divisive
issue um
i'm going to paraphrase i i want to
thank representative hagen phillips for
presenting good legal arguments and i
would just paraphrase what she said and
directly quote my own high school civics
teacher who said
the right for someone to throw their
fist stops at the next person's nose
this
bill is not about
um
stopping free speech it's just about
giving an area of protection for women
who are trying to get to their medical
appointments
these clinics
who may offer abortion services or
procedures also offer other primary care
services cancer screenings infection
screening
even if the intention is to peacefully
protest and i'm so happy to hear that
there are so many members here who do
have lawful respectful and peaceful
intentions
they are only individuals and they
cannot speak for everyone if there's
anything that i've seen in the news over
the last year it's that peaceful
protests often escalate into
non-peaceful situations
even just a year ago in january we saw
what happened when a peaceful protest
turned otherwise i think there's a lot
of opportunity
for harassment and intimidation
all patients have a right to access
health care services whatever those
health care services are without fear of
intimidation and harassment
this bill could have psychological
impacts
as well as potential physical impacts on
patients seeking medical care no one
deserves to be harassed so thank you i
hope that you oppose this bill
are there any questions for dr tolman
representative page thank you mr chair
thank you doctor for taking my question
we heard some testimony here that folks
will
stand outside facilities with signs that
say things like can we help we'll help
you
we can we can help you in your
experience
treating patients
um
is is it your experience that these
women who come for treatment have not
gone through
different levels of analysis about what
their decision
is yeah that's an excellent question
i think um it's short-sighted to think
that women are showing up to a clinic
having never thought about many
different alternatives
and
different courses of action and tried to
plan out what the best choice is for
them for their situation for their
personal health and for their families
i think it's a really challenging
decision it's a complex decision and
it's one that i have never really seen
i think it adds
a lot of
guilt and a lot of
psychological weight
to women who have thought long and hard
and come to maybe a very challenging
decision for their family to then come
and
and have someone
say
things that go against you know
potentially
options that they've considered
um i think it can be very traumatizing
especially for situations that we've
heard about today for victims of sexual
abuse for victims of incest there are
situations in which
an alternative can not really be an
option for someone there's also i would
just
again say that there's medical
conditions that make it very life
threatening for women
and to to hear that
representative chase
thank you mr chair and thank you doctor
for taking my question
do you in your
opinion if a buffer was put down and
we're talking 25 feet do you think that
people could still get their point
across if they wanted to pray or have
someone come over and ask for
information oh absolutely yes i mean
there are people who um
who speak up on either side with any
opinion
um
in front of clinics all the time and it
still happens even with a buffer zone in
other states that have had buffer zones
this just allows the physical space for
patients to get into a clinic without
having it in their face there's still
options if someone's on the fence and
they end up going to a clinic and they
change their mind at that moment and
it's because they saw a sign
then then that's that's still an option
for them um this is just protecting the
immediate physical space around them to
protect them from
from that direct
in your face contact
saying none thank you for your testimony
hi
i'm beth scare from nashua and um
i'm here to ask you to vote ought to
pass on hb 1625 the sidewalk free speech
act
seven years ago seven and a half years
ago then governor maggie hassan signed
the buffer zone
bill into law just over two weeks later
it was struck an almost identical law
was struck down in massachusetts
and in all this time no one's ever
posted his own
so all this talk about how these buffer
zones are protecting women
they're not they don't exist
there are none
and
about their concern about women being
blocked from accessing an abortion
facility
there's a federal law the freedom of
access to clinic entrances
which specifically
outlaws blocking access to abortion
facilities so no no
sidewalk no uh buffer zones are needed
to prevent blocking entrances
and um i've been volunteering with 40
days for life outside planned parenthood
in manchester for many years
and as you heard from beth gabes it's uh
twice a year well we have it twice a
for 40 days
and we pray we pray for the moms dads
the abortion workers
and everyone who participate participate
signs in agreement not to do anything
offensive threatening
don't carry signs with angry messages
block sidewalks or entrances
and
we we strive to be a model to everyone
on the sidewalk to be peaceful
to be a good you know we want to be a
good example for how to do outreach to
the women who are facing difficult
situations and the workers who are
working under very difficult
conditions
providing abortions
and
that's because that's not an easy job
when
you know yeah what you know is
you have to see what happens after the
abortion
and i just wanted to point out
that the love ring health center the
abortion facility
on the coast
in their own volunteer sign up sheet
they said that they no longer need
escorts because
ever since they moved from portsmouth
where they had a very small lot and
crowding on the sidewalk and they move
to greenland on a spacious lot with park
adequate parking a long driveway they
don't need escorts anymore because
they have no concerns about anyone out
on the public sidewalk there's plenty of
room
and
they what they used to have is what like
a quality health center has now what was
in portsmouth is what they're suffering
now in concord with a very crowded
sidewalk no parking for their um
patients
and
that's every minute okay and you know
the same thing's happening in planned
parenthood so all i would say is
if a business needs space i
highly recommend they get a bigger space
get a bigger lot
put some space between themselves in the
sidewalk and let law-abiding citizens
have their free speech on the sidewalk
thank you
any questions for ms scare
yes representative nader thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking the
question um just refresh my memory do
the people go and pray every day or just
on the days when they perform abortions
um during 40 days for life it's it's
seven days a week 12 hours a day in
other questions representative mclean
thank you thank you mr chairman thank
you for taking my question um you
mentioned the federal law um blocking
against blocking access do you happen to
know
that code i'd just like to look it up
i just know it's called the faces
the acronym is f-a-c-e-s
all right thank you
see none thank you monsieur
and
the last card i have is from jason
hennessey
can you hear me okay we can hear you
wonderful thank you mr chairman thank
you honorable members of the judiciary
committee for hearing me out my name is
jason hennessy i'm the president of new
hampshire right to life we are the
largest pro-life group that focuses on
life in the state of new hampshire and
we have thousands of members i'm here to
enthusiastically support hb 620 1625
this bill has little to do with abortion
and has much more to do with how our
government treats people exercising
their constitutional rights on public
property
as a state and as a country we decided
that free speech and the right to
peaceful assembly
is a core part of the society we want to
have
in new hampshire we have you've already
heard about the
constitutional article 30 and of course
the second or the first amendment in the
u.s constitution but we also have the
right to peacefully assemble and that's
new hampshire article 32 and of course
the second amendment of the u.s
constitution again
the only reason this law has not been
struck down in new hampshire
is because no abortion provider actually
thinks it's worth putting into place
you know you um how does it make sense
to single out the citizens who are
pro-life
to quell protected speech and assembly
we're talking about public property here
if it's private property that's an
entirely different business
and
and that would be a different debate but
this is public property
so why should abortion providers be
allowed to tell members of the public
what they can't say on public property
so uh
and what's next after that spanning
protesters from the sidewalks in front
of city hall based on what they're
saying if they're in favor of what the
city is doing maybe the state house
so if this were any sort of issue you
would have expected the abortion
facilities to have taken advantage of
the law to put one of these into place
but they haven't
and i've also in listening to the
testimony i've heard no uh quantitative
measures of police reports for instance
that would actually demonstrate that
this is a real problem
it's been over seven years you would
expect there to be something
in conclusion i'd like to point out
several parallels with another debate
that took place in this country
um over what many people saw as a great
oppression of of silenced people slavery
in this case you had a well-funded
slavery business versus mostly violent
volunteer abolitionists
um because because they had because the
slave business had so much uh influence
they were able to do things like
outlaw debate
you know the abolitionists were crafty
and so they discovered that the us
postal service uh was a way to get
around this and so then the the the
slavery business then went
into congress and they had that outlet
as well
here in new hampshire
planned parenthood spends multiple
millions of dollars in lobbying and
advertising every year
but as far as i can tell from the
pro-life that's three minutes thank you
as far as i can tell from the pro-life
side we are uh almost all volunteers
and so i enthusiastically asked you to
place new hampshire on the right side of
history and to repeal rsa 132 37 through
40 by voting ought to pass on hb 1625
thank you very much
thank you questions for mr hennessy yes
representative chase thank you mr chair
and thank you for taking my question
you uh mentioned a couple of times about
being silenced i don't see anywhere in
this bill unless i'm missing it that it
says that you're actually being silenced
or that
i'm going to say planned parenthood
is trying to silence people a buffer
that is not even in effect but even if
it was is 25 feet
it's two parking spaces you're not i
don't see where silence is coming in
here so i'd like you to either be able
to show me that or explain it a little
sure thank you thank you for your
question
so so i guess the
to address your question um
i believe that this would create a
barrier to entrance for by intimidating
people who are on the opposing side
also even if it's just 25 feet that's 25
feet of public space not 25 feet of
representative
thank you mr speaker thank you for
taking the question
i was on this committee when that buffer
zone first passed i don't know if you
were there but i recall some of the
testimony from that day and the people
that lived across the street who i
believe still live there their little
girl has grown up um i believe they said
that the 25 feet puts them in the middle
of the street
is that correct
um so it depends on which clinic you're
talking about i yeah 25 feet would
certainly
i believe is longer than the sidewalk
thank you for your question
representative
see none thank you mr hennessy thank you
mr chair
is there anyone else who hasn't spoken
who would like to testify today on house
seeing no one we will declare the
hearing closed
thank you everyone and
seeing no further business this
afternoon we the committee will be in
recess until tomorrow morning at nine
o'clock
so
uh
right
you have to be in this space
is
oh
maybe
hopefully
you